there's no time
[Music]
the time is 13. o'clock
[Music]
whoops
hey you guys what's up i was so
distracted by tom's look that i cut i
was pushing the wrong button
[Laughter]
would shock you [ __ ] back into
reality or whatever passes for reality
in in tom's world yeah
well it's not me it's everybody
everybody's version of reality is all
[ __ ] up from legacy
oh my goodness yeah and i'm right eye
dominant and i got this [ __ ] covered up
so i'm [ __ ] when he first you want to
hear something funny when he first got
that uh eye patch
because who said you say the eye patch
oh [ __ ]
my boy over in mexico yeah um so he got
the eye patch and he put it on and he
was going out of the bedroom into the
bathroom to like look at it in the
mirror and all i heard was dope [ __ ]
yeah and i was like did you just run
into something because you can't see
yeah commercial
he's calling himself murder hornets now
yeah that's right that's right that's
the bee's murder hornets i don't want to
say his real name on auntie on camera
i almost i was thinking about saying i
was like no i i try to remember that no
i don't say his real name
he's gonna use his screen name i mean
unless people use their real name
i mean i'll use it because i use my real
name because i don't give a crap but you
know what i mean but yeah granthar
samber says one could argue that fast
food has massacred millions through
obesity diabetes heart disease and other
medical ailments caused by eating super
super sized fried food uh again you
actually you absolutely could uh argue
that
you know if you eat too much of it
the sad thing about it uh when i was uh
researching this i think senor stix said
uh yeah fast food massacre is only in
america you don't even know the half of
it because there were so many
that i had to like narrow it down
you know what i'm saying like i had to
narrow it down i have five but i don't
know like how many of them will get to i
basically went with
like at least the ones i could find like
the ones with the
highest body count isn't that terrible
uh because there's two specifically that
i really want to talk about because they
were really bad
it's not just america either that's a
that's the most common misconception
brazil's a lot worse for shootings a lot
worse
but uh it's not america yeah but so this
was kind of like
one where
i mean there's two big ones i want to
talk about and then there's three other
ones that i hope we can get to talk
about
uh you know if we get to them that were
you know that were bad too
but
yeah it's kind of like a little bit of a
depressing topic yeah um but you know is
there any anything that we uh need to
talk about before we get into the grim
[ __ ] or because i know we don't usually
start
we don't usually start granthar says i
love that these two are so punctual
yeah that's all me i have to say i'm
well i'm always i'm not aware of what
time it is yeah he said well i mean i
know i've always been like that it's
nothing to do with you it's like i'm
always yeah i guess it was because
growing up
my mom was always late for everything
and so i kind of went the total opposite
way where i'm always like early for
everything so i'm always like i mean i'm
sitter i'm literally like sitting here
like 15 minutes before the show starts
making sure all my notes are right
making sure everything's working
correctly you know [ __ ] like that so i
always try to be early for everything
then i jump in and [ __ ] all that up and
then you jump in and [ __ ] it all up
yeah
that's how you do thomas the agent of
chaos i carefully plan everything and
then i'm just like well
why do i even bother you think i would
have learned by now just to like not
even bother with it rappers knows what
up we came out of [ __ ] trauma school
together man we were [ __ ] we'd ad lib
like crazy
you know
soldiers of fortune like us would just
make [ __ ] up
just pure
it's on the edge of pure memory and
talent
is that what that is yeah i like your
little yeah
you're a little cocky ass
booby wiggle there
[Laughter]
dj maniac says hey look a gay pirate
yeah
yeah you lost my eye now you need a
pirate hat too yeah i mean i like i do
like the cock-sucking hat but
now you definitely need a pirate yeah i
lost i lost an eye and a [ __ ] gang
bang
what someone
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
oh my god
uh
yeah uh danny rolling ghostface mentions
paul dennis reed uh i'm actually gonna
get to him yeah uh he was actually
he's not gonna send me some money for
talking [ __ ] about him yeah every time i
talk [ __ ] about zack he pays me
he's into that i guess
uh
senor six games were like has tom escape
from new york or el
salvador escape from new york or l.a a
la pliskin style escaping from these
dicks
yeah
all the dicks they're coming after you
trying to send me money sure tom needs a
peg leg says you know
oh yeah that's the next thing
you're so badass you should go the whole
hog and just like cut your leg off at
the knee and then like oh hell no i am
stupid
[Laughter]
i'm just saying no no i'm not stupid but
yeah no danny rowling brought up uh paul
dennis reed and i actually do want to
get into him because he's like a serial
killer but
in the sense that he killed
people over three different fast food
restaurants you know what i mean so they
call him the fast food killer so i
definitely wanted to cover that case
as well although the first two i'm going
to cover are i definitely want to cover
those because they were like
the worst not only the worst fast food
massacres but also
uh until you know more recently the
worst mass shootings period like in the
us you know what i mean
so uh we'll get into that in a little
bit oh i wanted to mention before i
literally just found this out
like 10 minutes before we went live
you guys remember on one of our
creepiest disappearances shows it might
have been the first creepiest
disappearance that we did and i don't
even remember when that was
um we talked about
brandon lawson
and
how weird a case that was literally if
you google weirdest or creepiest
disappearances ever
brandon lawson is almost always on that
list i mean it's a weird ass case if you
remember it happened in 2013 it was in
texas
uh he was out in his truck
and he ran out of gas like this and he
was like on the phone with his dad and
then like he said people were after him
and all this others and then he like
vanished and they never found him
they think that they might have found
his remains
they're not they're not positive yet
because they haven't got the dna but
they did find uh a bunch of his clothes
and a bunch of bone fragments that then
they know the clothes were his thank you
very much cam guy he just sent a super
chat ten dollars
thank you very much thank you thank you
very much been wanting to do this for a
week or two you guys deserve it thank
you very much thank you very much but
yes so
um so yeah they they think that they
actually might have found him now
that doesn't mean that they know exactly
what happened to him they're treating it
like a homicide but they're not entirely
sure if it was a homicide or not you
know what i'm saying now they actually
ended up finding his remains
pretty close to where they found his
truck abandoned and some people were
like wigging out about that like you
know law enforcement they didn't really
do a good job of searching if he was
like right there the whole time but i
think the property that they found him
on was like private property and the
people who owned it
didn't live on it i guess so i don't
know why law enforcement never contacted
those people to like search their
property because that's where the body
was apparently like the whole entire
time but
uh they have apparently found
uh brandon lawson so there is that like
i said i don't know if they're ever
going to figure out what happened to him
but him them finding his remains i mean
i'm sure that will be
you know that will help in like figuring
out what happened to him
uh stop prop says what did i click on
tom what leather daddy
went man i've
i mean what did you think was gonna
happen
i'll go back to normal what did you
think was gonna happen
senor stix says what is tom and jenny
drinking today we got this sunrise you
got a tequila sunrise this is what is
this you made it that's uh it's coconut
vodka coconut vodka and pineapple
pineapple juice it's good which so it's
kind of like a pina colada i like malibu
but it's a lot stronger yeah a little
bit
cheryl says remember to switch eyes
periodically to avoid headaches
i just took it off the eye patch yeah
yeah because otherwise you're gonna like
at the end of the show you're gonna be
like i can't see
because you'll get so used to like not
having that one eyeball whatever yeah um
but yeah so uh what else we need to talk
about before we get into the [ __ ]
anything oh no
like nothing exciting has been happening
because we were just on yesterday right
i thought we were supposed to have
another work dude come today but he was
going to come but then he said he he
wasn't able to make it oh okay
he's gonna deal with other clients too
yeah well all right so he yeah cause i
just
figu i found out about it like a couple
hours ago and i was just kind of like oh
well he's yeah and then he shows up i'll
do it i don't think he's coming
well yeah i mean it's past yeah five now
so that dude will work into the night
time
yeah yeah well i don't know okay well he
doesn't
did we ever check the mail by the way no
no i don't think i checked it yesterday
either
it's a long-ass driver yesterday oh okay
made you think of that where did you
show i don't know well i don't know just
because i thought of uh i don't know it
was just all part of like going outside
or like things that might come to the
door or something like that
what are you gonna turn the fan on yeah
it's weird because it's not hot outside
for some reason
did you leave the heat is the heat still
on
oh
he had the heat on last night his
hormones maybe
maybe yeah yeah you had the heat on last
night because the heater like dried my
throat out and i woke up coughing
um let's see uh tom and jenny have you
enjoyed a tom collins which is an old
drink i don't think i've ever had a
tomahawk it's like a little man drink
yeah like i've heard of it but well yeah
but the thing about it is that tom
collins might be such an old man drink
that it might have like turned around
and become cool again i don't know old
man drinks were mostly involved the
worst the worse it tasted the more manly
it was
like [ __ ] some of that [ __ ] is just
like you drink that you're like god that
tastes pretty [ __ ] bad oh yeah that's
what you're supposed to drink it this is
so it's supposed to suck they're like
yeah
well as i said it's kind of i think it's
one of those situations again where
it's more manly to eat or drink
something that tastes like ass yeah then
actually have something to taste good
you eat something that tastes good
you're soft yeah exactly like martini i
think martinis are [ __ ] terrible i've
never had a martini i thought tasty it
depends on what i've had ones that were
good but most of the ones i've had were
not good yeah probably the ones that
tasted good didn't taste like martinis
yeah i think that was the case yeah
they were always like some kind of like
a flavor like a holiday drink or
something that had some other kind of
stuff in it
yeah i'm not i'm not a big fan
you know but what you know what are you
gonna do
uh let's see oh some danny rowling's in
there selling jokes
what's thick and white and comes on your
burger than mcdonald's employees
[Laughter]
what does a gynecologist and a pizza
delivery driver have in common they can
smell it but they can't eat it
not you
that is pretty nasty i shut that down
off topic saw a documentary where they
said sid vicious killed nancy have you
ever heard if he did yeah yeah um i
think it was an accident you know what
we should probably do a show about that
one of these days
i don't think
i think they were both so [ __ ] up that
they didn't know what the [ __ ] was going
on to be honest with you
she he stayed
she got stabbed somehow yeah
they were constantly trash they were
constantly fighting
she didn't go run off to help for help
she stayed in there
she died for a couple days after she had
been stabbed if i remember correctly
there was there are signs that she had
been stabbed she was in there for at
least a day
so it's not like she was running away
and trying to get away from him
she was also only stabbed once
there's no proof that he stabbed her
she may have stabbed herself she was
that kind of girl or they were [ __ ] up
and like it was an accident it's an
accident
but she turned he woke up she is dead
she had been stabbed some time before he
bonded out
in his uh he and his mom started
shooting up heroin afterwards and he
died of an od
most people believe that he would have
been acquitted
because
there was no
the evidence pointed away from murder
yeah
no it wasn't murder
some kind of accident
i mean at the very least it would have
been like
manslaughter i kind of feel like that
probably would have been the worst they
wouldn't be able to prove that
yeah i don't think there was enough
evidence
she was not trying to get away from him
she had been stabbed and she stayed up
in there with him at least 24 hours
they've been trying to like stop the
bleeding and stuff and then they got
high again got back in bed she was back
in bed she died back in bed with him
so she wasn't running from him
like i said they were both so [ __ ] up
they probably didn't even know what the
[ __ ] was going on
and
you know you hear sadly sid vicious you
think that man this [ __ ] must be
a beast he was a little bitty skinny
dude okay uh and uh was he was not
physically imposing at all
he slept most of the time
a bad heroin addict
nancy could probably whip his ass she
was a bit older than him and probably
she might have been stronger than him i
i don't know uh
but he was not a
[ __ ]
physically imposing
dude and he was not
violent
um she was the one that had the rep
the reputation for being [ __ ] crazy
and evidently she had attacked him
several times in front of other people
start slapping him and kicking him and
[ __ ]
yeah
although dj maniac says sid vicious was
an abusive [ __ ] that killed cats
um
i had heard rumors that was mentioned in
a song but the thing is is who knows if
that actually happened
those guys [ __ ] made up a lot of [ __ ]
i'd have to look more into it because
it's been a really long time according
to john lyden there wasn't anything to
him really
they got him in there just because of
how he looked
i don't think he was abusive to nancy uh
if most people were according to john
lyden
they were trying to get rid of her
because she was like [ __ ]
controlling everything he did she just
kept him
kept him loaded kept him [ __ ] really
high
she was from new york and was pretty
street wise she's all hooker you know
and um
sid himself was actually kind of a
[ __ ] naive
kid
and and he grew up pretty much addicted
to heroin his mom his parents were at
junkies
yeah dj says i'm fairly sure it was
confirmed by several people from that
clique
uh well just because you kill a cat
doesn't mean you murder your girlfriend
yeah but it's still not good i mean does
that mean that's still no doesn't i
don't know i know you're good girl no i
still don't think he did i think he
murdered her i don't think he murdered
her either but i'm not i don't think
that means that was that he was a good
dude though
um well i didn't really say that yeah i
just well yeah that's all i'm thinking i
was a physically imposing person he was
weak
he only weighed 135 pounds maybe 100 i
have no idea max
a little skinny guy
dj maniac says along with the fact he
went to lemmy and said i can't play bass
and all lemmy said in response was i
know
[Laughter]
oh lemmy
uh yeah so we're talking about stabbing
camp guys said my first cousin was a
hemophiliac and he got a bad nosebleed
and bled to death he was about 50 to 55
years old um i don't know if i've ever
mentioned this on the show but
hemophilia runs in my mom's side of the
family
yeah several of my aunts have it which
is unusual because usually women are
just carriers and they don't have it uh
but in my family several of the women on
my mom's side do actually have it to
greater or lesser degrees and a couple
of one of my aunts
uh she they
begged her doctors begged her please do
not ever have a baby because you will
probably bleed to death uh but she
wanted to have a kid anyway so she did
and they had to do
i mean she lived and she's fine uh her
daughter is like grown up now
but uh you know they had to do all these
transfusions and stuff like that for a
long time my mom was worried she kept
like trying to get me to
go get tested
to see if i had it
but i don't think that i do
and i have had surgery and nothing bad
happens no you're not so
your your blood clots yeah
but it does but it does run in my family
and actually one of my female
cousins had a little boy who has a
full-blown hemophilia also it came from
my grandfather actually he was also a
full-blown hemophiliac um something else
just occurred to me too i remember
somebody who was talking about
an attorney who had looked at sid's case
and said that
nancy spelungen her sponges spun is that
her name nancy sponge and her her
autopsy and everything [ __ ] looked of
shady
um i'm gonna write it down so and that
um
cause of death wasn't [ __ ] uh
wasn't [ __ ] a hundred percent with
that
i mean yeah she she had had a stab wound
to the abdomen
and there was some bleeding
but she she that may not have killed her
she uh
she may have died of a heroin overdose i
mean they were doing lots of [ __ ]
drugs
prosecution wanted to say it was murder
but they always do
that would be something that would have
to be adjudicated
um i don't think he would have ever got
convicted
it's just
the
supporting evidence didn't support
homicide i'll have to put it in the poll
because that actually would be i know we
talked about doing hurt i know you
talked about doing that as like an
episode and for a long time and then but
sometimes when i go to make the polls i
forget
that's why i started like every time
somebody suggests something like i'm
like oh yeah and then i write it down
yeah and then the next day i like put it
on a list that i have over there
you know so i don't forget those guys
were very political they were [ __ ]
when i say political really
they were [ __ ] media sensations
the media wanted bad [ __ ] to happen to
them everything about them was
sensationalized
so
him showing up in the newspapers [ __ ]
accused of murder oh they loved that
they ate that up but they're probably
not true
well as with everything uh you know
things are a lot more nuanced they
appear at first blush
like i said it wasn't a good situation
but i don't think that he intended
to
murder her i don't want to you know like
i said at the very worst it would have
been manslaughter and i don't even think
they would have proved that evidently
nancy didn't think he was trying to
murder her because she didn't run off
yeah she stayed right there
yeah janet says they were in a cd hotel
too yeah that was chelsea wasn't it i
think yeah there's that one where all
those artists go to that's yeah that was
that kind of famous one that one where
like uh where uh what's her name that
that was in andy warhol's thing
what was her name
where she like burned down that hotel
room or something i'll think of her name
in like five minutes yeah chelsea hotel
so he goes to jail for a while they bond
his ass out
and his mom [ __ ] hooks him up with
some smack and they shoot up and [ __ ]
kills him of an overdose
yeah well somebody said well he killed
himself i don't think so
not a great family situation really i
mean oh everything was against him
that's what i mean
people like that i just it's sad because
you just never really have a chance in
life you can't pick your [ __ ] parents
right yeah he was
born addicted yeah because i think his
mom was addicted [ __ ]
when she was pregnant with him so he'd
have been born addicted
yeah it's like i said it's just really
sad that's yeah you're born like that
you don't really have much i mean you
have such huge handicaps in life like
you know yeah it's hard we didn't live
long how old was he
19 or so when he died 20 maybe
i thought he was 21 21 maybe 21.
yeah i know awful
yeah that's just that's a newborn from
my point of view
yeah i mean 21 you know the [ __ ] going
on that's a [ __ ] kid
ah it's like it's terrible terrible
all right so uh do you want to start
talking about this uh
food massacre go ahead thank you good
thank you hannah you bid
so here's something i was kind of
curious about this
because i was researching all these
different cases and trying to
figure out which ones would be the best
ones to talk about and then i kind of
got curious i know it doesn't really
matter in the grand scheme of things but
i was kind of like i wonder which
fast food chain has had the most
massacres or the most murders happen at
it
i couldn't really find that information
um mcdonald's keeps coming up but i
think that's just because there's a lot
of those you know what i mean although
as let's see let's see if if tom knows
this
mcdonald's is actually i think it's only
the second most numerous fast food chain
in the us and in the world do you know
what the first one is
what
you don't want to guess
he doesn't want to guess he's no fun do
any of you guys know it's not mcdonald's
i know most people would probably think
it's mcdonald's but it's not
um thank you janet that's really nice
you are amazing thank you thank you
is that a little pear
i think it's a little dancing pair i'm
into it he's cute
he looks like he has a little olivia
newton john let's get physical that's
what i don't know why i thought of that
uh but yeah so it's not mcdonald's the
number one most ubiquitous fast food
chain in the us and in the whole entire
world is
subway
oh that's because they're in all the gas
stations yeah
so
because i thought i wouldn't have
thought it was subway
i would have thought
maybe starbucks
they're up there too but
it's not it's subway
uh so i don't know like i said a lot of
massacres that i don't know it seemed
like all over the board there were a lot
of them at mcdonald's uh there was a
couple at wendy's there was a couple at
bk
most of them thankfully are not these
kind of like huge like mass murder
events some of them are just people and
it's largely robberies
which i'll get into a couple of those
but the first two that we're gonna talk
about were absolutely not robberies
you know what i mean it was just like
[ __ ] crazy ass people like coming in
there and [ __ ] just mowing people
down
um
subway so everyone eats fresh then yeah
i guess so
yeah somebody guessed kentucky fried
chicken no yep it's subway grandpa's
hammer new
that's yeah i totally would not have
guessed that but yeah
so but one thing that i did find i
couldn't find out which fast food
restaurant had the most murders in it
but i did find out uh
on the fbi website
that of the
this is gonna sound bad
of the 706 okay 675
517
violent attacks not murders that's just
that's murders
robberies assaults rapes that's all
violent crime there's of all of those
incidents
in 2020 in the united states
two percent of those occurred inside
restaurants or bars
uh not just fast food restaurants had
could be any kind of restaurant or any
kind of drinking establishment
uh so of those
there were 76 murders
uh that took place in restaurants and
bars and that was just 20 20.
and you know as i said but i don't know
because i didn't know if somebody would
ask
like what fast food restaurant like had
the most murders in it and i was just
like so i was trying to find out but i
couldn't really find out i don't feel
like i said it's generally it doesn't
really matter because the thing about
fast food restaurants they're not even
the most commonly i mean i think banks
are still the number one hit like for
crimes robberies
uh but fast food restaurants are up
there
usually just because
fast food places they're usually right
by highways a lot of times uh usually
they're pretty they don't have a hell of
a lot of security as you know opposed to
like a bank or something
they're open all the time they're a lot
of them are open late into the night or
open all night uh a lot of the employees
at them are younger like teenagers uh
things like that they don't tend to have
the same protocol like with the safes
uh yeah there's it's there's a lot of
things that make them like a soft target
or an easy target for robberies although
like i said these first two cases i'm
talking about were absolutely not
robberies well there's you can see all
kinds of [ __ ] on youtube social media
what goes down i did some some of those
places i mean fist fights [ __ ] gang
fights going on inside [ __ ] the
chicken places it took like
in the morning it was pretty [ __ ]
wild i've seen videos of [ __ ] denny's
restaurants
after the after the bars closed just
burst out into big [ __ ] fights
well yeah because it's fighting well
yeah because the thing about it is that
you know you have people damn drugs yeah
going after the bars like you go to
denny's or waffle house or whatever like
mcdonald's isn't open 24 hours anymore
but
you know people used to go there like
you know if like in downtown orlando
because like the pizza place or like you
know go to get tacos or whatever stuff
that's open all night after the bar is
closed you're just asking for trouble
yep just asking for trouble that's why
these rich people are trying to go
zardoz on y'all they see them videos and
they go these [ __ ] gotta go
these savages
savages
um let's see largest purse store
uh camp guy says largest per store gross
sales of any fast food place each
franchise doubles the average mcdonald's
sales 2.5 million to 5 million
um
[Music]
granthar says there's a chain in detroit
called popeye's chicken yeah i thought
those were everywhere
yeah we have a we had a popeyes uh
not like a mile or two from our old
house and i think we only it's it was
pretty new too i think they had just
built it like a year or so yeah ago and
even here in the south even in louisiana
they'll tell you that's the best red
beans and rice you're going to get
i think i even put that in the cookbook
i mean that's pretty much i really
haven't heard anybody dispute that
assertion
popeye's red beans and rice is kind of
like
the southern equivalent of [ __ ]
mcdonald's french fries hard to beat
mcdonald's french fries even when when
they're hot although most people say
like after five or ten minutes they're
garbage although i'll still eat them i
don't care but you know what i mean
there's i don't mind when they're called
kind of made a comeback they're they're
pretty close burger king fries are good
they're new ones i mean burger king's
fries used to blow chunks they were so
bad they were always
i feel like i don't eat at burger king a
lot and i didn't used to eat at burger
king a lot um
but
back in the old days their french fries
were just they it seemed like they were
always burnt or they always like
overcooked them always kind of soggy
soggy we'll see that's just my every
time i got them they were they were
burnt yeah really consistent but they're
they're great now
some people say some people like them
better than mcdonald's but mcdonald's
has had the best french fries for
[ __ ] decades my whole life and like i
said consistently consistently good they
have had consistent friends and they
haven't really [ __ ] with them too much
wisely
you know what i mean if you can get a
big old thanks go go to [ __ ] go to um
um popeyes just to get a big old thing
of [ __ ] red beans and rice just sit
there and eat that
the chicken's good but yeah i can just
eat the red beans and rice i mean
frankly we don't eat a lot of fast food
um
even you know when back when we lived
near some like you know we'd sometimes
we'd stop at mcdonald's like on the way
home from the bar or whatever but
we don't really eat it all that much so
i don't really keep up with a lot of
stuff although i will say that most fast
food places have really upped their game
lately because
by necessity i would i would assume
just because well because fast food kind
of was declining a bit because you know
well no the yeah the fastest growing
segment was kind of like the fast
casuals you know like boston market or
not boston market necessarily but like
chipotle uh you know uh not boston
market who might have panera like stuff
like that where you just order at the
counter and then go sit down boston
markets like that yeah but i know but i
i was just saying the boston market i
think i i mentioned that but i don't
think that's doing as well even though
boston market every time i ate there was
pretty decent i don't i haven't eaten
there for years but i used to eat there
quite a bit and the barbecue place is
good too
which one the one we have here
uh
when i see it i [ __ ] know what it is
you can go in there and get it
you can uh order like three selections
of this and then two sides and what
sunnies oh man i think i might know
the only big ones i know are sunnies and
woodies i think it might be it's either
one of the two
okay so one over there across the street
from it's right next to bro to boston
market over there near the chinese place
at 434 and i4 that intersection i can't
remember i'm not i'm not hugely into
barbecue so i guess it doesn't really
like the right word register you've
eaten that three or four times it's good
but you can't think of it i mean i don't
know the name of it i just know where it
is oh okay
uh cheryl says i think mcdonald's tastes
like fried
cardboard depends on what you get
honestly i kind of like uh i don't even
remember what it's called but they have
like a pretty decent like chicken
sandwich i like the chicken sandwich
that has like all the veggies on it you
know what i mean
i've got that a couple of times and that
always seems like pretty good look the
only issue with mcdonald's that i have
is sometimes they put too much
mayonnaise on stuff i'm not complaining
too much because i like mayonnaise
but
sometimes they're a little heavy-handed
with the mayonnaise gonna say but it's
better than having no mayonnaise i
suppose
can't complain too much
um and i mean mcdonald's breakfast
sandwiches are like
particularly the sausage mcmuffin
is pretty goddamn good
uh kyle's recommending sid and nancy the
1986 movie yeah that was actually really
good uh with gary oldman in it
uh we only have cheryl says we only have
mcdonald's in subway here it's so
disappointing
yeah i mean
we have
[ __ ]
what do we don't have that much around
here we have well we do have a subway in
the gas station in the circle k
it's called smoke house four rounds oh
okay i've never smoked oh yeah yeah yeah
i don't even is that a nationwide chain
or is that just around here i know
there's more than one in orlan in the
orlando area but i don't know if that's
like
i don't know if that's nationwide
because i know that some chains are
regional you know what i mean yeah so i
don't know if everybody has that
i don't know if everybody has that or we
just do
that's what we have here
yeah four rivers that's right yeah
that's really good
like i said i'm not if i'm gonna go out
to eat it's like barbecue is never the
first thing i pick
you know i don't know why i'm just never
usually in the mood for it
my
when i was growing up my parents used to
go to like to go to sunny sometimes
and i'd always just get a fish sandwich
because i wasn't into
you know i just wasn't into it
it's good i just i was just not that
into it
um so yeah we have all kind of like fast
food stuff you know what i discovered
today there is a channel on youtube and
it's called
it's kind of like it's a little bit on
the side of tasteless but then i was
kind of like now i'm into it and it's
called dining with death
and she
talks about a crime that happened it
either a crime that happened in a
restaurant or a crime that had something
to do with food in some way and then on
the second half of the show
she makes
like the food in question or she makes
something that was on the menu of the
restaurant where the crime happened
because i saw the one that she did about
one of the cases that i was doing
and you know so she talked about that
and then like she made
an italian beef sandwich or something
like that like at the end and i was just
like what a weird
i mean it's kind of like a genius idea
but it is kind of weird too
cheryl says they only haven't done
subways yeah yeah she's in um
um
australia isn't she i think so yeah
see i thought but
well i'm trying to think of like because
i felt like most of the world has almost
all of the same chains that we have for
sure
everybody's got mcdonald's everybody's
got subway i thought most places had
kfc's
i thought most places had bk what about
wendy's though oh because i feel like
mcdonald's wendy's bk those are like the
three big ones what's funny is that in
and out burger won't leave california i
don't understand that they were good
yeah and
carl's jr i haven't seen that outside
california i know it is outside
california but it's not here well carl's
jr and hardy's are owned by the same
company and it has the same logo because
we have hardee's but i think it's
either the exact same menu or it's very
very similar okay like they even have
the same carl's jr used to be good
because hardy sucks
parties are bad yeah it's like we would
go to there was a hardee's behind the
gas station near our old house if we
were going in a particular direction
that was like the only food for like a
really long time
so sometimes we would go through the
drive-through
and get food in there but every it was
cheap i will give it that yeah the
patties are soybean though but that
patty
yeah it was just never all that good
sometimes the fries were okay if they
were fresh but the sandwiches always
tasted kind of weird the bread was good
everything the toppings were all good
and then when it got down to the [ __ ]
meat the meat wasn't any good it just
tasted real artificial so probably just
get a box full of french fries and a
biscuit
just go carb bomb on the [ __ ] don't even
bother with yourself carl's jr used to
have these deep fried burritos they were
[ __ ] great back in their early 80s
about back in the 80s
they become a salsa you dip it in there
things are about that long they're
really good
see i bet they don't even have those
anymore they came in a damn box kind of
like a kind of like a mcdonald's hot hot
apple pie they were like that but it was
a it was a burrito
they deep fried she was awesome
cheryl says she's in british columbia
canada oh okay okay three hours north of
spokane washington
grantham's hammer said thailand had all
the american fast food places but the
meat tasted weird like it was half cow
half yak
maybe it might have been you remember
when i was when i was growing up
i had an uncle
and he always said because i used to
like wendy's right
um i liked that their burgers looked
like they were actual meat and not just
like a frozen patty
but he when i was little he used to tell
me it's like well the reason it looks
like that is because it's made of worms
so he just kept calling them wendy's
worm burgers
and after a while i was just like well
if they're worms then they're delicious
worms so [ __ ] it
jenny didn't believe me when um
when uh jack-in-the-box
got caught serving [ __ ] wallaby
wallaby instead of beef no i heard about
that okay i thought it was horse meat
though no it's wallaby wallabier
kangaroo wallaby i believe
which is about the same thing smaller
which like i said it's not getting wrong
it's not going to kill you it's just
that people didn't know it's good
quality meat yeah real good quality i
mean if you say that that's what it is
then i don't have a problem with it i
think the people the problem had to be
you know because people thought it was
beef obviously well they were saying 100
pure beef that's what i mean yes no it
was wallaby so it's not so much it's not
so much that it's wallaby meat it's that
it's your advertising is something that
it's not that's the only problem i have
with it
um camp guy says mcdonald's has a
proprietary ground beef cut i don't know
what it is but it's the same ratio for
each burger
like it could be for example 30 chuck 20
flank 30 sirloin something like that
yeah maybe that's bad meat it's good
meat i mean maybe that's why their
burgers taste like pretty consistent
yeah
across the board mcdonald's for sure are
one of the ones that are like really
strict about their
you have to do everything like this one
specific way and i think of all the fast
food chains that i've been to and like i
said i haven't been to a lot
but
mcdonald's usually the food is
is consistent like it usually tastes the
same from restaurant to restaurant
as long as the management is up to stuff
snuff yeah sometimes they'll be in
places where
management sucks and the [ __ ] the
people that they hire in the area
[ __ ] suck and
i wouldn't eat there but they're
inspected by the franchise
if they don't meet standards they
[ __ ] shut them down
because they used to let mcdonald's like
that run back in the 70s and the 80s i
remember them yeah but they tightened up
quality control
well like i said the competition uh
particularly in those markets is so
fierce nowadays that you really can't
afford
to i mean [ __ ] just stuff like having
yelp and stuff like that where people
can complain
um you know all it takes is like a few
bad reviews and that's like going to
tank your business so you really have to
like keep your [ __ ] nailed down yeah the
bit the big chains realized it's more
efficient and better for them to close a
restaurant down
than to leave a [ __ ] up one standing
that's where those [ __ ] what they
call them food deserts come from you
can't hire anybody in those areas they
can't run the place they can't can't
staff it they'll [ __ ] it up
so
there's no restaurants there it's not
just one it's all of them
tammy says i watched the show the other
night gordon ramsay was cooking camel
meat yeah yeah well there you go ruby
real lean [ __ ] well yeah well yeah but
you could do [ __ ] with it i mean there's
other meats that are really lean that
yeah you just slow cook yeah you just
have to know what to do with that [ __ ]
in a crock pot
uh camp guys says mcdonald's also owns
and grows uh and processes their own
beef yeah i knew about that i mean it's
a massive business they have their own
[ __ ] uh they grow their own beef
potatoes and many other items in their
supply chain including the tractor
trailer trucks that deliver the meat one
of my ex-girlfriends from way back in
the day when in boston when i got out of
the army moved to boston
she worked for a company that
arranged
calls you know big big [ __ ] mass
calls between companies this is before
they had skype you had businesses that
did that for companies so she was
constantly doing these calls for these
corporations linking all these people
together they're having a whole sales
conventions going by phone
and she used to do mcdonald's all the
time
and she would overhear all their reports
and she said that the mcdonald's
headquarters told them that
that they had
saved and it was like some amazing
amount of money like two million dollars
uh the prior year because
they
because the rate of failure for slices
of cheese got better in other words and
it was only like a one percent that that
the cheese failure rate improved
by one percent and it saved him two
million dollars
yeah i was like damn you don't think of
that
well saved two million dollars because
there was a one percent improvement
in people [ __ ] up slices of cheese
and dropping them on the ground
that's all they're talking about yep
drop slice of cheese but if you got a
[ __ ] ton of
stores yeah out of cheese over the years
that you [ __ ] drop is the [ __ ]
million bucks that changes by you know 2
million bucks if it changes by a
percentage yeah when you're a company
that's that large yeah
um yeah any kind of little change like
that it doesn't sound like that big a
deal but over the vast empire it makes a
massive difference and she's sitting
there basically earning just above
minimum wage thinking [ __ ] these
[ __ ] are not dropping cheese
just by just just slide them out and
[ __ ] she could live the rest of her
life on that two million dollars
isn't that depressing to think about
yeah that they just like talk about the
[ __ ] casually over the phone yeah they
saved two million dollars yeah yeah and
they were and because of that they were
able to give out bonuses to the [ __ ]
upper upper management yeah meanwhile
all the workers on the ground like yeah
please sir can we have some more yeah
management is getting we give you
[ __ ] a new two hundred thousand
dollars you know the [ __ ] there's a
house
gee thanks and all i had to do was write
a memo saying stop dropping cheese on
the floor jeez right plebes
thank you give me my two million dollars
that was mid 90s
jesus yeah uh adriana says i'm in
honduras and we have at least most of
the american fast foods pizza hut
mcdonald's little caesars wendy's
popeyes churches burger king denny's
dunkin donuts and kentucky fried chicken
i never been to honduras never been
there
me neither yeah
i don't even know what the capital city
is
i feel like that's something that i knew
at some point but you know
just
age and alcohol was just eating holes in
my brain i think honduras used to be
a province of mexico didn't it
i think maybe i'm trying to remember
where that is
is that remember that's north of [ __ ]
panama or south of panama i don't
remember i think it's south i think it's
north of panama
gramps or sammer said i never worked in
fast food but i did work in a butcher
shop in high school one time i was
grinding a burger and noticed a band-aid
on my finger was missing i'm sorry 35
years later to whoever ate it well
hopefully they didn't eat it hopefully
they saw it before anything happened
they brought it back to the store
uh camp guys said mcdee's trying to get
crafts to make their cheese taste just a
little bit cheesier and they wouldn't do
it
the small dairy they ended up working
with became a multi-millionaire business
yeah i guess so if you get the call from
[ __ ] mcdonald's to make their [ __ ]
holy crap i can imagine
just from selling cheese to mcdonald's
yeah because i mean
i'm pretty sure mcdonald's is the second
largest in the world
second largest fast food restaurant in
the world after subway as i said so you
know anything that's gonna buy [ __ ]
anything that large is gonna buy cheese
off you then yeah it's gonna be fine
uh late night alcohol and fast food is
asking for trouble
yeah i mean
we used to we used to hit waffle house
sometimes
back when you know when you lived over
near that waffle house
so we would stop there because that was
open all night
and denny's was open all night went to
denny's a few times too because i always
want breakfast food like when i'm drunk
i always kind of want breakfast food
like i always want something egg based
you know like a sausage muffin or
t-shirt
something i don't know
what is what does cheese normally taste
like
it's cheese but make it taste cheesier
you know what i'm saying
yeah it doesn't mean anything to me well
and the thing about it is like what kind
of cheese are you talking about because
all cheese is kind of tasty
no one like blue cheese
man i was watching this is this what are
that velveeta
no mcdonald's was asking kraft to make
their cheese taste cheesy
yeah
and craft would know for cheesy cheese
because they make that [ __ ] mac and
cheese and that's been like the favorite
mac and cheese in the us and canada i
got although in canada they call it
craft dinner
that's not funny i got some this
eternal dry storage big old [ __ ]
big can of dry cheese it comes out of
powder
i thought it was gonna be kind of like
the powder that you that comes with
macaroni and cheese it's not
it's got a bunch of different recipes
and in one of them if you mix it one to
one with water
it turns into this stuff that's kind of
like
like a yellow
glue
it tasted all right but it's like man
this is kind of sucks so i took
an immersion blender
and whipped it
and it turned into cheese whiz exactly
like cheese whiz
that might be a better applique i'm not
a fan of it in its gloopy form no turned
it into cheese whiz by whipping it
then you were like i invented cheese
whiz again and the other one i have is
dry butter
you can add butter to it to a certain
amount the dry butter and they said you
could whip that and it turns into it
into
into a light cheese spread is what they
called it
like put it on
crackers
i'm just learning how to how to work and
be fancy and then i had these
sausage toppings
they're dried and you add put water to
them and they rehydrate they're great
for pizza turned out that's what pizza
hut's using
i kind of figured yeah that's what pizza
huts use them i mean i love footballs
yeah i mean when you made it the first
time yeah and you showed me you're like
you showed me the can and you're like
this is what i'm going to put on the
pizza and i was just kind of like
dubious yeah but it does actually taste
like it tastes pretty good actually it
tastes good and it does taste like
yeah like pizza hut or something like
that like their sausage and then and
then the toppings that they use for
bacon it's just bacon bits
the you know i mean the uh the moist
bacon bits i get those that sams they're
good none of that [ __ ] is cheap though
it's almost kind of
in a way cheaper to probably make it
it's just the convenience
well yeah convenient stuff there's
always more and the storage
that stuff you can store it forever it
doesn't have an expiration date
yeah be up there for 40 years
long after we're dead we'll come in here
in the closet and be like look at all
this powdered cheese powdered cheese
what the [ __ ] were they doing in here
they must have been so constipated
powdered cheese and powdered butter
and then you can make the cheese into
and you can put rotel in it you know and
and make um
nacho cheese dip with it
yeah yeah my mom makes that all the time
i want to cook it on pizza and see what
it tastes like no don't do that don't
waste some of your nice pizza crust okay
with that with that yeah that's going as
soon as possible i mean yeah but
the thing about it though it's like look
if you're going to spend money on food
and if you're going to spit
it just wait if you're going to have
that just wait until the zombie
apocalypse and then we can then we'll be
happy to have any food while we before
the zombie apocalypse let's have food
that is enjoyable that's true but you
know what that was nice and great that
cheese would be good with what it'd be
good inside of eggs wrapped up inside of
a flat flour tortilla like a like a like
a breakfast burrito would be good for
that i don't know because like a couple
times you made that cheese stuffing
and put it on like an omelette or
something and i didn't like it i thought
it was too
it tasted like it's cause i didn't whip
that candle wax or something i didn't
whip it i didn't like it i scraped it
all right
that's just cheese whiz it's cheese whiz
i know but i don't want cheese was on my
own
it was too much it was like too gloopy
we got to get back to the task at hand
we got a show yeah i know okay oh this
is do you want any ice on that yeah okay
yeah put some more ice in there all
right do we it's the ice maker like
still yeah we turned it on like a little
bit ago but it's not full i didn't have
enough in it
oh okay
um
oh somebody's asking about the austin
texas yogurt shop murders i was i was
gonna cover it but then i decided not to
because there were like so many other
ones that came up i do want to cover
that on another show though i did
actually write about it in my
book
um
i don't remember what volume it was
probably the third one but yeah but that
was one that i considered but like i
said there were so many to pick from and
i was like oh my god i'm never gonna get
to all these so but that's another one
that i want to cover on another one
because that was like pretty horrible
so uh all right so i decided to go in
the order of
um
this is [ __ ] up but i decided to go in
like the order of most people killed
to decide like which ones to do
so the first one i want to talk about is
the looby's massacre or the looby's
shooting i think is what it's called on
wikipedia
now looby's we don't have it here um
i think they're i don't even know if
there are still any locations of this
still around
it's kind of like a fast food restaurant
but it's more like a cafeteria style so
it's like a fast casual type of
restaurant and most of them were like
around the texas
area like i said i'm not sure if they're
still around or not we never had them
here in florida that i know of uh but
yeah
so for a long time this massacre which
happened in 1991
was uh the worst mass shooting in u.s
history
uh at least until the virginia tech
shooting in 2007 surpassed it sadly
but from 1991 to 2007 this was the
number one
so the guy that did this [ __ ]
was george
hennard hennard or henard
um
i didn't however i don't know he's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] nut so i don't care how you
pronounce his last name
uh so let's talk about the day
of the massacre and then we'll get into
like his history and [ __ ] like that
so this guy uh
as he had been doing for
a while like a year or more
george hennard stops at a convenience
store this is in belton texas
very very early in the morning october
16 1991
as i said he stopped in there pretty
much every morning uh to get
high pookie to get pretty much the same
uh breakfast
now the girl that worked there she had
seen him many times before because like
i said he was always kind of in and out
of there um and she always said she was
really like scared of him he seemed real
unstable he seemed very hostile
uh you know not very friendly always
kind of scowling and [ __ ] like that
but she said on this particular day
he was acting totally different like
she's ringing up his purchases
which
uh you know donuts candy bars [ __ ] like
that
uh but she said today he seemed really
like friendly and calm which she thought
was very weird because usually he came
across as you know like a hostile dick
now
i guess the reason that he was so calm
and happy that day
was because he had made up his mind to
go
and do a [ __ ] mass murder
so he was in a good mood
this is so [ __ ] up
so seven hours after
this girl saw him at the convenience
store
he turns up at this place looby's in
killeen
killeen
uh texas which was 17 miles away from
the convenience store
uh and it was around lunch time
and the restaurant was actually pretty
busy there were 150 people in there
all of a sudden
george oh hi pokey look at she's like
what i don't want to be on she stuck her
head into like the quirk of his arm i
don't want to be on tv
[Music]
oh
look at that baby look at that baby look
at that little face look at that little
face
she's like yep i'm putting up with it
i'm putting up with it
yeah so uh so here's the restaurant
there's 150 people in it and then all of
a sudden uh george hennard
drives his ford ranger pickup truck
through
the front window
and then he well he was actually
shooting before he got out of the truck
but then he jumps out of the truck he's
got two nine millimeter semi-automatic
pistols
and starts like blowing people away
so uh as it turned out that day on
october 16th was national bosses day and
there was one guy in there named sam
wink who was 47
and he and some of his uh fellow workers
had taken their boss to lunch that day
now they were uh sitting at the table
like right in the front where right
where the truck crashed through the
window so like glass came in and
everything
and uh so as i said george hennard was
like shooting from inside the truck
before he got out
uh they said that he he jumps out and he
has a pistol in each hand he has a
cigarette hanging out of his mouth and
he has like his shirt his belt
everything like that or just like
ammunition
right
so then he starts going down because
like i said this is cafeteria style so
you just like pick up a tray and then
you go through and everything's kind of
there so you just like pick it up so he
starts going down the serving line of
customers and just starts shooting
people
like that
now
this guy in particular
um
[Music]
was
little bit of a misogynist let's call it
that
he was seemed to be specifically
targeting women
damn divorce laws um he wasn't married
though i don't think which is i'm just
making [ __ ] up i guess so
i mean he comes in
he starts shooting people right and he
comes in and this is what he said and
several like people and survivors that
back this up he said
all women of colleen and belton the two
towns uh right there are vipers
see what you've done to me and my family
and then
who [ __ ] knows
so he just goes around like shooting
people and like a lot of times like you
know if it was a woman he'd like put a
gun in her face and be like you [ __ ]
and then he would just shoot her in the
[ __ ] head yeah you know what i mean
yeah and then he would say stuff like
tell me is it worth it
being a viper what the [ __ ] is he even
talking about
yeah so uh his mind just [ __ ] up i
guess yeah it's like this one woman was
like because a lot of people obviously a
dude comes like crashes through the
window and starts shooting like people
already started diving under tables and
whatnot and so he starts like going he
shoots a bunch of people on the line and
then he's like shooting
people underneath the tables saying
stuff like hiding from me [ __ ] and
stuff like that
and um
the one guy who was at the table at the
near the front like he lived um and he
said and this is a quote from him that i
found
he says uh he was about 12 feet from me
when he turned our eyes met for a second
he said there was a smirk on his face as
if he was thinking i've been waiting for
this a long time
he was very intense well prepared almost
as if he had practiced at home
and even though he was yelling he was
very calm
the contrast between the fire and his
eyes and the calm on his face was
unbelievable that's what he said so this
guy just like walks in and he's yelling
but he looks totally like emotionless
and a couple of other people that lived
said that too that he just looked
completely emotionless
um
so there was another guy there now his
[ __ ] psychotic fantasy i guess it's
just like getting even tonight [ __ ] i'm
getting even with you yeah well it
wasn't even tonight it was lunchtime
yeah it was the middle of the day it's
gonna be kind of like that korean kid
that ran into that damn university and
shot up the people with the 22 and the
uh and the other little nine millimeter
pistol he was he was totally sure he
made whole videos about how
they're gonna get what they deserve
after what they did to me and everything
they've been saying about nobody knows
who this dude is this was another
[ __ ] like that and actually the
next [ __ ] we're going to talk
about was kind of like that too it
really does seem like there's a
particular type of person
that does and they think that
everybody's talking about them yeah it's
like what kind of like weird narcissism
like nobody knows who the [ __ ] you are
like nobody owes you anything
i think what his name was
he had he had uh like a certain type of
schizophrenia
and uh he believed he believed that he
was being persecuted and that people
were um
talking bad about him and making fun of
him and that they were oppressing him
and but nobody even knew who he was
well that's almost always the case yeah
look at like when we talked about that
[ __ ] elliot roger [ __ ] face yeah
where he just has these you know he
would walk by a woman and if she didn't
smile at him or like acknowledge him in
any way that was like some big [ __ ]
slight and he's like well i'm so i'm
gonna get back at everybody in the world
because somebody didn't notice me one
time
it's in their imaginations yeah
obviously i'm like how [ __ ]
narcissistic do you have to be to think
the whole world has to like turn around
and pay attention to your dumb ass
well i don't think it's narcissism in
the normal sense of the word i think
it's uh it's a schizophrenia it's like a
hallucination
they're hearing it but they're hearing
it in their heads yeah
they'll be saying that to them but they
they think it is they you know
but uh
they that dude released videos he put it
out on the internet but what what was
that
2006 maybe well if you're talking about
the virginia tech shooting yeah
virginity checks
which like i said this was the biggest
uh mass shooting in us history until
virginia tech which was more victor a
little more victims than this but that
was 2007. if that's a virginia texture
it was 2007. and then the poor
korean-american community thought that
there'd be reprisals that
that oh man the white people are going
to kill us
well that'll be even [ __ ] noticed you
know well that's not crazy to think that
because it does happen sometimes it
didn't happen though no not in that case
people did not really korean people but
it does happen sometimes yeah it was no
everybody knew that that dude was crazy
didn't have anything to do with the
[ __ ] koreans
yeah well you know not to do with korea
the fact that people know things doesn't
always mean people don't always behave
logically in those kinds of situations
like when it's really emotional like
that in that case it's good that it
didn't happen but there had there
definitely has been like backlashes
before like about that kind of [ __ ]
but not in that case
um so yeah where was i doo doo doo doo
doo okay so there's another guy there
who uh was 31 he was a chiropractor
uh he was there with his wife uh their
baby daughter and his parents
and uh so basically he he had a friend
there
um named steve ernst now steve ernst was
hiding under a table and this
chiropractor dr isdale he looked over
and saw george henry shoot
steve in the stomach
then
uh he shot
ernst's wife judy in the arm the bullet
went through her
and killed another woman uh venice
henahan who was ernst's mother-in-law uh
judy lived i think
um one thing that george hennard would
do too it's like he was very methodical
like he would shoot people and then
if
you know if they you were still alive he
went back and checked and like he shot
him again he wanted to make sure like
everyone was dead right the only time
that he stopped was to reload
uh they said the only
time that he showed any mercy at all
weirdly
he pointed a gun at a woman
who he just shot the woman's mother
but the woman was holding a baby or like
a three-year-old and he said you with
the baby get out
and she ran away but that's the only
thing
that's the only way that he did that the
only time that he did that
um one of the survivors they said so
like i said it was just constant gunfire
and then there was silence while he was
reloading
and they said the weird thing like some
people did try to run out and everything
but most people like i said we're just
hiding
um and the one guy who was at the table
near the entrance like or near the
window when he crashed in he says i
guess everyone was waiting their turn
you know what i mean so it's almost kind
of like yeah uh so there's this one guy
tommy vaughn who was a mechanic he was
28 years old
and um he was kind of like
scrunched down by a window
and he saw the shooter like coming
toward him and he's like oh [ __ ] the
dude's gonna shoot me so what he did he
was a big dude he was like six foot six
and like 300 pounds he just jumped up
and
busted and jumped through the window and
broke it yeah did the right thing and
then so um out of here and so yeah so
because of him yeah um about a third of
the people got out because like as soon
as they saw that like everybody like
started pouring out the window yeah um
but they asked him later and he said you
know i'm not a hero or anything like
that he's like i was just by the window
i saw the dude he was gonna come over
and shoot me and it's just like i
thought well this is the way out because
he was like you know he was really big
so he just like jumped out the window
and broke it and a bunch of people got
out look i'ma tell you all something
crafters
experienced law enforcement back yeah me
being [ __ ] infantry
civilians have a weird
problem of freezing up in the face of
[ __ ] danger like they're like it's
deer in the headlights
they want to [ __ ]
somehow
keep to [ __ ] rules of normality and
[ __ ]
they're trying to maintain society's
rules in the face of death no
bust through anything get the [ __ ] out
don't worry about being rude don't worry
about survival guilt if the place is
burning down if you got to climb over
other people to get out [ __ ] do it
okay if you would have died anyway so
would have everybody else
so dude is a dude like that a hero yeah
yeah of course
because other people wouldn't have done
it
i'm not gonna break the glass
well i got my glass there's [ __ ]
bullets flying what the [ __ ] are you
talking about well
well like i said people aren't thinking
logically in that type of heightened
emotional situation you know what i mean
most people
happily uh are not put in these types of
situations every day so when it does
happen you don't really know
how to react or you might think stupid
[ __ ] you know what i mean well
he just thought of it because i guess it
just crossed his mind he's like hey i'm
a big [ __ ] dude i could probably just
jump out that window i don't even know
if he was thinking oh other people would
jump out after him i think he was just
thinking i gotta get the [ __ ] out of
here law enforcement emergency combat
type personnel
we don't think like normal people
because they would get put into
situations like that we've been we've
been vetted already
through all that [ __ ] we just break the
glass
or whatever or you knock somebody down
to get out of the way or there's no
choice you attack you know you bite
somebody you rip somebody's face off
just whatever it takes
to get it done
don't let society's
morals hold you back from survival
an evil opponent will use your niceness
and your civility against you as a
weapon
don't do it
when you have to think too particularly
in these mass shooter situations
is that one nobody's expecting it
because you're just at [ __ ] you know
a restaurant having lunch one day and
all of a sudden that happens um you know
for a long time it's just like and
you've seen it with school shootings too
where for a long time people aren't
entirely sure what's going on because
you just hear noises or you know you're
not seeing it and also like once it does
happen just kind of like the shock of it
yeah well because you're making excuses
well no i mean in this case it happens
so quickly i mean the dude just walked
just crashed through the [ __ ] thing
and just started shooting everybody yeah
i'm gonna crash out myself though i just
yeah i know exactly how to respond to
that
but you can't blame people for not
knowing how to do it like i said not
everybody i'm blaming them for it i'm
just kind of
i'm telling the audience
okay
[ __ ] do not freeze like deer in the
headlights don't do it
and if you think it's rude to break the
glass because it's not your glass you're
[ __ ] tripping people are being killed
mcdonald's doesn't care about that
[ __ ] plate of glass
they're insured anyway they're [ __ ]
insured and and [ __ ] they'd rather
have you jump through that glass than be
[ __ ] gunned down
and then everybody's went out that glass
because dude broke it
showing them the way out so he's a hero
yeah hell yeah he's a hero
he's he's he he had an expanded overton
window because of his size he realized
that the glass wasn't a limitation pow
let's go
that's how you do it yeah
you know and i mean like i said i'm not
even entirely sure if he was thinking
i'm just going to get out or other
people can get out i'm not i'm just
thinking i'm going to get out yeah
probably like i said hey i'm old enough
to like but then i'm big enough to like
you know bust that window up yeah but
that's all it takes because he's showing
the people the way
i mean sadly
um you know
sadly by the time he did that like a lot
of people were already dead yeah but you
know what what are you gonna do so more
of them would have died had he not done
that well yeah exactly because the dude
uh this george henry dude would seem to
have no [ __ ] uh intention of stopping
until everyone was dead there's been
planes that have hit the ground it's
caught on fire burst into flames and
peop and then people were trying to get
out
but they couldn't and then people in the
back were starting to burn up
so people would jump on top of the
crowds and [ __ ] climb over the top of
the people to get out and then they
lived and when they got out
they had all these mental problems you
know i mean this survivor's guilt that
they climbed over all those people
but then experts have gone back and find
out well who was sitting in these seats
that went down
and figured out why they couldn't get
out
and statistically the people that
weren't getting out
and holding people behind from getting
out those people were going to die
anyway
they were too old and firm and too
old and firm
and too wounded to have made it out
anyway so climbing over the top of them
was the best way
because at least that person would
survive
and the other ones because they all
would have died
had you not climbed over the top of them
so at this point
so at this point like you know like i
said a lot of people were already dead
at this point the cops showed up
this happened very very quickly it was
only like a few minutes so the cops
showed up and started shooting at george
hernard the gunman uh even while they
were shooting at him he was still
shooting at the customers
and then shooting at the cops
uh he did get wounded i think the police
hit him
between two times or four times uh
sources differ
uh so he was wounded and he kind of
limped over into the corridor where the
restrooms were
and uh which point he put the pistol to
his temple and blew his head off
uh at the end of the day he had shot and
killed
23 people 22 of whom died at the scene
one died later after she was taken to
the hospital and wounded 27 others the
whole thing happened in 10
minutes
from the time that he crashed through
the window until the until he shot
himself
uh it was the worst mass murder in us
history until it was surpassed by the
virginia tech shooting in 2007
uh so once once they you know got there
and tried to like do a post-mortem on on
the [ __ ]
and figure out what the [ __ ] this guy's
deal was so let's get into this
asshole's uh history
um turned out uh not surprisingly he
didn't have a lot of close friends or
anything so a lot of people didn't
really have a lot of impression about
him but most people that they uh
surveyed
said that uh you know again
unsurprisingly he was a loner very
sullen very hostile very withdrawn
um he actually came from quite a wealthy
family
um
a lot of people also pointed out he was
uh really really hated women
really really racist uh really really
homophobic so you know the [ __ ]
trifecta he had all of it uh he also had
a really really violent temper uh nobody
knows particularly what triggered him to
quote-unquote snap if you want to call
it that on this particular day
it didn't seem like there was any one
thing
but
who [ __ ] knows he's just a psychopath
probably yeah so uh so okay so let's
kind of go into his uh history here so
he's born in pennsylvania now his dad
was a uh was an orthopedic doctor
uh so from the time he was five years
old um hennard his mother and he had two
younger siblings
uh moved across the country a lot uh
because his dad worked in army hospitals
now as a younger kid
a friend of his that knew him said when
he was kid he seemed quite cool and
quite popular quite outgoing very
friendly
um you know nothing
nothing particularly he was a good
looking kid and you know a lot of people
seem to like him and stuff
but then a year or two later when he was
still quite young
uh he came to school one day and
apparently he'd been in a fight with his
dad now his dad
had a reputation for being also having
kind of a violent temper being sort of
uh physically abusive
so
he comes to school one day and his
friend says he looked like he'd been
mauled it looked like his old man had
taken a butcher knife and cut his hair
he was never the same after that he was
completely introverted so i guess his
dad kind of started beating on him
uh or had been beaten on him the whole
time but it just went too far one time
and after that uh he wasn't uh the same
he just went very introverted ever
didn't talk to anybody uh he never got
seen with girls he never hung around
with anybody so like i said a loner um
his parents according to his friends his
parents didn't really seem to care about
him uh weren't really around all that
much
he graduated from high school in 1974
joined the navy
and then three years later uh signed up
with the merchant marine and uh ended up
working in the gulf of mexico until 1981
and uh went on a whole bunch of uh
overseas voyages and stuff now he was in
trouble with the law in and out a lot
like during this time
he got arrested for marijuana possession
which you know that's a [ __ ] charge
but okay uh in texas in 1981
and he had his siemens paper suspended
uh
not because of that but because he got
into this big fight with one of his
shipmates uh and it was absolutely
racially motivated uh as i said he
really did not like black people and he
really did not like hispanics and was
not shy about uh telling everybody about
it too so he got into a fight with a
black man and he got his uh paper
suspended
yeah one of his friends or actually his
roommate said he hated blacks hispanics
gays he said women were snakes he always
had derogatory remarks about women
especially after fights with his mother
that was what his roommate uh friend and
roommate said sounds like they beat him
and he just [ __ ] went from from an
early age and he just became a mad dog
the weird thing about it is that
um we've seen this a lot with uh other
serial killers of this ilk
and it seems weird because a lot of
times they have abusive dads the mom's
not always like abusive sometimes she's
abused also
but the strange thing is that
it seems in a lot of cases that a lot of
serial killers or a lot of dudes of this
type will kind of like i guess because
they can't fight back against their dad
who actually did beat them they always
kind of like move the anger over to
their mom yeah because she allowed it
because she allowed it even though the
mom was sometimes a victim as well not
always but sometimes attacking them from
being weak yeah so it really does save
me you couldn't save me yeah yeah
that's what it is and yeah that's you
see that a lot like in the psychology of
these types of dudes so then all of a
sudden the anger and the hatred turns
towards the weak yeah yeah yeah because
you didn't prevent it right and then he
becomes his father
yeah
yeah and it's just it's i've you know
i've seen it with cases like this
man over and over again it's over some
weird [ __ ] and he's probably not aware
of it that's another thing he's probably
not aware of what he's doing
yeah because from the outside it seems
very obvious but his internal world is
that
the world is against me i'm the victim
he probably thinks he's the victim yep
yeah these women got they you know they
hurt me
that's yeah that's what it is yeah that
sounds exactly like the weaker type of
twos yeah the weak hurt me yeah because
they couldn't save me yeah from the from
the master
yeah they deserve what they get
yeah and then he becomes the monster i'm
the monster now
yeah well that's what they're doing
they're trying to be more monstrous than
the person that well
they don't develop
too well and uh iq probably has a lot to
do with genetics
early childhood
the way they're brought up
they can't they don't have the ability
to be introspective they can't think
their way out of it because this [ __ ]
happens to a lot of people but they
easily can think their way out of it
well you're only seeing the people who
couldn't
that's why i always say that it's not
just genetics and it's not just
upbringing it's a it has to be a perfect
storm it has to be a combination of
those things because a lot of people had
shitty ass childhoods
a lot of people
but dudes are much worse than that yeah
or much worse than that that turned out
fine that turned out absolutely fine you
know lovely citizens but there has to be
that added component
to to turn them into that yeah you know
what i mean it has to be like all of it
has to be there
so 1989 uh he lost his siemens license
again for marijuana possession again
aboard a cargo ship
uh so he goes into a substance abuse
program in houston
and kind of like became not necessarily
a drifter but he didn't he couldn't
really keep a job for a long time uh he
would work on like construction crews
and [ __ ] like that uh he was living with
his mom uh his mom had divorced the dad
in 1983 and she had the house
and it's apparently like a nice house
like i said because this was a rather
wealthy family so he was living uh with
his mom in henderson nevada
now february of 1991 uh which again
which is the same year that the massacre
took place he legally purchased two
pistols a ruger p89 and a glock 17
in henderson nevada and uh during that
year his behavior was becoming uh
very weird like i mean it was weird
before but it was like getting weirder
this is really weird so there were these
two sisters who lived um a couple blocks
away from him in belton texas their
names were jill fritz who was 23 and uh
janet jernigan who was 19.
he seemed to have developed
a weird
obsession
stalking relationship with them he wrote
them a five page letter in june of 1991
saying something like you think the
three of us can get together someday
please give me the satisfaction of
someday laughing in the face of all
those mostly white tremendously female
vipers who tried to destroy me and my
family that's what the letter said like
i mean it was five pages but that was
part of what it said
so
i don't know why he had a particular
like
uh you know
these girls were just kind of like we
hardly even know this dude what the [ __ ]
i don't know cookie's back there on that
chair sitting there looking at me like
she's gonna talk the whole time she's
exasperated
where no no she's not she's like she's
you are and you're trying to make you're
trying to make it seem that like the
cat's mad at me she doesn't care if i
talk i talk to you she's if she's doing
the show i'm doing the show pookie
sometimes she's like why are they
talking to the lights again well yeah
she's just mad because we're not paying
attention to her that's what it is she
doesn't care if i'm just she doesn't
mind if i talk she likes me to talk
that's why she sits in here she's
talking
that's why she sits in here all day with
you know what i noticed what's that what
the [ __ ] is tila
where's tayla she commented on a couple
of the youtube videos but i guess she
maybe her work schedule changed or
something and she can't what about
sandra
what about sondra oh i don't know i
haven't seen a long time
the germans did something bad to her
maybe well no because i think she
commented on one of the recent videos
but i just think she hasn't been in the
live stream well like i said everybody
can't like drop by in the live stream i
know right
i know that looking for them girls
[Laughter]
that's a man oh you brought up that
conspiracy theory against the conspiracy
the tila is a major conspiracy theory
well i don't know nobody's conspiring
nobody thinks that hard about anything
conspiracy theories they just like to
believe them
[Laughter]
because this big conspiracy theories are
coming true lately
yeah okay yeah okay
tom's tripping yeah he's he's he's
putting his words in the cat's mouth
that's what he's doing
i'm trying to keep her in check it's
gonna be okay she's not doing anything
she's just sitting in the chair she's
chilling out there being cool she's
chilling out with the people you get
over there and be cute okay
well yeah she can't help that yeah
uh so yeah so he had done this [ __ ] like
a few months before the massacre a week
and a half
before
uh the massacre
he uh picked up his last paycheck at
this cement company where he'd been
working and he said he was quitting
now according to his co-workers manager
stuff like that they said that he also
said aloud i wonder what would happen if
i killed someone
and uh one of his co-workers bubba
hawkins said he got to talking about
some of the people in belton that's in
texas and certain women that had given
him problems i'm not sure what women
he's talking about unless it was he was
mad because he wrote a five page letter
to those girls and they didn't answer he
probably imagined these women uh yeah
that's kind of what i'm thinking yeah
and he didn't know him
not really it's like you know it's i
think they lived a couple blocks away
and they just maybe
yeah he'd probably seen them and they
were just kind of like we don't know him
from adam he's going to hung chol or
whatever that dude is well like i said
that seems like some elliot roger [ __ ]
too because it's just kind of like oh i
see these women and like because you're
talking about because you like them then
you think that they must know that you
exist it's like they don't know that you
exist there's billions of people in the
world just
yeah um yeah so bubba says and he kept
saying watch and see
so you know it's a little ominous
october 15th was his 35th birthday
so he talks to his mom on the phone for
a little bit i don't know what they said
that night uh he goes to a restaurant in
belton
and on the tv in the restaurant was the
clarence thomas uh confirmation hearings
when anita hill came on like they were
interviewing anita hill what year was
this 91 okay
um
the manager of the restaurant said the
dude stood up at the table and started
screaming you dumb [ __ ] you bastards
opened the door for all the women
that's what he said to anita hill on the
tv okay
so that's the kind of [ __ ] we're
dealing with that's kind of what he's
crazy yeah no kidding
uh notably and i don't think it says
this on uh wikipedia or anywhere else
but i found this elsewhere
uh he had seen recently and i think they
might have found in his pocket when he
was dead uh a
theater stub for it
uh the movie the fisher king which came
out in 1991 now if you guys haven't seen
that movie it's jeff bridges right and
robin williams in that movie jeff
bridges plays like a shock jock and one
of his listeners
inspired by something that he said like
goes and uh
shoots up a restaurant in manhattan
um so they thought that was interesting
that he had just seen that like right
before the massacre took place also
um he had actually read about the
[ __ ] we're gonna be talking
about next james huberty
um who had done a massacre in 1984
so it might be that that's where he got
the idea to get back at the world
or whatever by like shooting up a
restaurant so
i don't know what they're hoping to
accomplish but okay
i think this is around this time
grapplers might remember
i think it was in michigan maybe
somewhere outside dearborn
a guy from the middle east did the same
thing and it was in a restaurant slash
bar held him hostage for
24 hours did a bunch of other sexual
[ __ ] killed a bunch of people he's from
the middle east he spoke a little bit in
english though
it was around this time late 80s
is that did did you run across that one
uh
okay it must not have been because i
kept doing searches for i was looking
for ones that were like the worst ones
in terms of
amount of deaths there's been a [ __ ] ton
but the vast majority of them were
robberies like people would come in and
like to rob the place and then they
would just like execute the people in
there and i might talk about a couple of
those but
i i wanted to talk about these first two
particularly just because it was the you
know robbery was not the motive and
because the body counts were so high
okay i mean pretty much these first two
i mean this first one he killed 23
people and then there's another and then
there's a couple that i want to talk
about where it was seven people
and then from there i was i'm not saying
that it's like great that it was oh it
was only four people or only three
people or something like that but
i mean i wanted to kind of talk about
mostly the worst ones
you know what i'm saying because
somebody asked about the austin texas
like the yogurt shop murders and i said
i actually wrote about that in my book
and i was thinking about talking about
it for the show but i just you know
i thought well maybe we can do another
episode like we can do another volume
because there's so many yeah there's so
many
it's just like [ __ ] it's crazy but to
me like i said
america is a big place and i think it's
well one thing that i thought was
interesting too and i kind of used this
like when i wrote my books is that
one of the things that i wanted to do
because i said if i just wrote books
about like every unsolved murder ever
then it would be like 40 bajillion pages
long so yeah
so you have to kind of like winnow them
down so i said well i wanted to have
ones where
robbery wasn't the obvious motive
because i mean obviously it's terrible
if somebody's shot in a you know a
liquor store robbery or fast food
restaurant robbery obviously that's
awful
but it's understandable there you know
you know why it happened i was kind of
more interested in
[ __ ] like this where it seemed
motive-less and random is like much
scarier sense that it happens in
restaurants though and and and places
like bars
because if a dude [ __ ] pops a gasket
and [ __ ] goes crazy he's gonna go
where people are well yeah and they're
gonna be there yeah
what's weird is that it didn't happen
more often in shopping malls i think
it's almost kind of like the area that
did happen in shopping mall it has but
malls are big they're big and i guess
they're not personal enough you can't
keep the people confined
yeah they're going to a restaurant where
it's more confined
so it's a better target for them
now schools is a better is a good target
too because it's just hallways and
they're in those you can keep confined
in those classrooms
so you know it's thought out the dudes
that do this are thinking about it yeah
like theaters it's pretty confined
you know so you got a good field of fire
um
but it's you know america is a big place
time is a large concept over time [ __ ]
happens
um it's actually got a lot better uh 70s
and 80s was [ __ ] super violent well
that was yeah that was the worst i think
a lot of it was like i said unleaded
gasoline leaded gasoline i think had
something to do with it
um just uh no
no no computer communication between
counties much less states so it was
easier to get away with [ __ ] if you were
moving
it's just the environment was a lot
different you could get away you could
have a bad [ __ ] and he could
commit multiple multiple murders before
he even became a suspect it was a lot
easier back then and cameras weren't
everywhere it's not like it is today
today's a lot harder you could do
something like this but you'd get caught
so you couldn't do it more than once
i mean it could unfortunately in this
case i mean once was more than enough
because he killed 23 people
but
yeah you don't see i mean well i kind of
feel like that's why you see more if you
see crimes like this it's more like a
mass shooting mass murder situation
rather than serial killers there are
still serial killers around don't get me
wrong
but i don't think there's as many i
don't think there's as many and they've
had to
change up their tactics i don't think
the environment that created serial
killers that too there's a lot of facts
not around anymore i think that's part
of part of it is the environment it's
not as common the environment that you
know i mean yeah and uh but uh yeah it's
just uh
it's it's an ever-changing environment
so certain things go in and out of style
and um
you know
i really think man
i'm [ __ ] glad that somebody backed me
up on that from the [ __ ] professional
from the with a more professional
background that that leaded gasoline had
to have had something to do with it yeah
because i've read that in other places
too so you're not there i don't think
that's the only factor but i definitely
think that's a factor i think it was a
contributing factor oh yeah big time i
remember [ __ ] growing up in l.a as a
little kid barely able to breathe my
eyes just [ __ ] hurting from the smog
that was before the catalytic converter
i mean i remember hearing about it i
didn't live in california then but i
remember hearing about how soupy the air
was over yeah and that was leaded
gasoline so there were lead particles
blowing around everywhere and i remember
kept copping a bus off of carbon
monoxide and not being able to breathe
so
who knows how that had affected adults
who grew up in that environment their
whole lifetime you know what i mean it
when you hear this when you read this
stupid [ __ ] some of those 70 serial
killers were doing yeah the
[ __ ] were [ __ ] they were
under the influence of something
that's not normal shit's not normal that
goes back to ancient rome where they're
drinking out of lead pipes and [ __ ]
yeah you know and it was the rich people
that were the most affected in ancient
rome because they had plumbing and they
were eating awful lead plates and stuff
and they were added adding powdered lead
to their food as a [ __ ] seasoning and
only a rich person could afford that and
that's why the [ __ ] rome was
run by her maniacs [ __ ]
crazy
yeah
food with madness yeah
[Laughter]
and they were [ __ ] taking drugs on
top of that we don't know what drugs
they were taking it's just that they
said they were taking
[ __ ] they would just name it but we
don't know what drugs they're talking
about
so who knows
i can't imagine like what kind of
[ __ ] crazy ass [ __ ] i'm surprised
people lived past the age of [ __ ] 20
back then they would order the [ __ ]
legions to do insane things and you know
the
rome had a [ __ ] crazy ruling class
for a while
danny rowling says i'm surprised there's
not a lot of cannabis dispensary
robberies
yeah they don't see may i don't know if
it's just because they haven't been
around for that long or
violence is not around as much
it's yeah i mean generally
you know obviously it still happens but
it's been on the decline
i mean we have some ups and downs here
and there but i think in general it's
been on the decline since the 90s or the
late or the late 90s you see crazy
political violence here in the united
states and weird these were these riots
and [ __ ] which are destructive
their [ __ ] society over and it's
divide and conquer type deal but still
if you look at the raw numbers
the modern era is nowhere near as
violent as the 70s in the 80s like i
said i'm just nowhere near i don't i
don't like i don't complain about [ __ ] i
mean it's you know i write about true
crime so you i have to be situationally
aware when you're somewhere because you
have bad like something like this could
happen yeah i mean it does happen
um
statistically
you probably shouldn't worry about it
yeah it might happen but it all depends
on what area you're in
you know and another thing that we
haven't talked about on this episode
is the vast scope of the missing persons
in the united states children and girls
a lot of them missing a lot of them
never found
yeah yeah
well i mean talked about that
well honestly like i said i was thinking
i was thinking about doing
uh a book series because you know i did
the unsolved murder trilogy i was
thinking about doing a trilogy about
unsolved disappearances
and the more i looked into it i'm like
oh my god this would take forever years
to do there are so
many yeah and so many and and the scary
thing is like so many are not identified
if you ever want to like
lose faith in everything
go to like the wikipedia page of like
you know unidentified murder victims
there's a [ __ ] it's so long and that
doesn't even cover all the ones those
are just like the main ones that have
their own wikipedia page you know what
i'm saying there's like dozens more than
that if you go into because this is what
i what i did when i was writing the
books is i would you know i'd start at
wikipedia but then i would like uh go to
other articles and then i would go to
each state's database if they had a
state database of missing persons or
murders unsolved murders or whatever
because a lot of states do uh that you
can go into
and once you do that
man like just florida alone
i'm like that's like a whole series of
books right there yeah all the unsolved
murders and disappearances just in
florida yeah
and uh tell you what man it all starts
peaking 70s and 80s 60s 70s and 80s
those area era eras were pretty bad
it's not as bad as it was you can't go
missing
as easily as you could back then
you can go missing it's just there's not
as many of them back in those days
people went missing
never found or found and you you'd find
a body you wouldn't know what body that
was of some you know 14 year old girl
but the pattern was me and jenny
established the pattern
collapsing areas either it's a city
that's economically collapsing
or a rural area that is collapsing for
some reason or another
like a company moves away or a road
moves or a freeway is built
which draws the traffic away from that
area
and it starts to economically collapse
incomes go down and it's kind of like
predators move into that area like
maggots feasting on a rotting corpse
and they just
take civilization down with it and it's
a long process if you saw it sped up in
fast motion it would probably look like
a body dying
but you know in normal time it just kind
of looks like an area slowly getting
poorer and the crime rate
rising up and people moving away
but that's the process
it's not a lot of it was canada i
remember
a time ago about um a whole rash of uh
it was right around well actually it was
right around toronto or like this area
around toronto and it was just like this
one it was from like the mid 60s to the
mid 70s i want to say
and there were
at least four serial killers
probably more operating in that same
exact area at that in that same exact
time period i mean there were so many
unsolved murders
um and they think it was not necessarily
because the area was collapsing but
because
uh several new highways had just opened
up coming from other
places that you know previously had been
hard to get to
so it was almost kind of like predators
were like woo hoo it was good no it's
not okay
it just says yeah it said it said
disconnected and now it just now said
reconnection okay yeah i know i can see
look at it
well i can see where it's going now
right yeah now it is now it is all right
uh maurice hooker says did you guys talk
about the mcdonald's massacre in the 80s
i'm going to talk about that next
actually that's the next case i want to
talk about yeah right now we're still
talking about we're talking about how
areas of the
uh massacre yeah we were talking about
how areas were collapsing
and serial killers and missing people
and all that [ __ ] would happen in
collapsed areas it didn't matter if it
was uh [ __ ]
rural or urban just anytime the [ __ ]
economy goes way south and the
population starts to decline it's kind
of like
a collapse
and murder rates go up
detroit it was [ __ ] bad for like 30
years man
and i lived in second west hancock in
detroit for about a year 18 months
and i saw several dead bodies one of
them was in the damn dumpster behind my
[ __ ] apartment
didn't do feet sticking up out of
dumpster
and it was just
black dudes shooting each other
uh finding [ __ ] dead black girls
[ __ ] raped dead inside the abandoned
houses it's that same theme over and
over again
then burning down houses
burning they would just burn down
abandoned stuff
and then eventually in the more modern
era they said look this place has got to
go they would just send bulldozers in
there to [ __ ] bulldoze entire blocks
of abandoned houses
there's nobody living in them anyway
they were just
places where [ __ ] crime would happen
and man the [ __ ] it was the murder
capital of the world during that time
just a [ __ ] rapidly declining
population through homicide
it's a [ __ ] spooky phenomenon man and
it was pre-internet people outside
michigan really weren't aware of it only
michigan knew about it it was like a
local event
you can go on youtube and see those
abandoned uh
abandoned houses most of them are gone
now it's just spooky man
it's like something out of those urban
exploration videos
mad max
josie says i grew up in the bronx back
in the 70s and 80s oh yeah back and
forth
yeah dead bodies and lots were common
that was the son of sam days yeah i mean
new york in general was kind of a
cesspit back yeah that's back when new
york wasn't worth the [ __ ] i mean way
not like that anymore i haven't you know
i i well last time i was there was
probably 2009 2010 something like that
new york was a rich neighborhood now i
mean i heard it's headed it's all been
gentrified it's had an economic downturn
recently we'll see how the trends
continue
but um
if it gets real bad like gary gary
indiana's gone you know that's it
gary was kind of like a mini detroit
canada says look into the chicago
strangler yeah which is one i don't
think
i really hope this [ __ ] stream is not
gonna like give me problems tonight
because i'm going to get really angry
about it yeah xander said detroit never
got better actually detroit did get
better because most of the people were
gone now it's detroit is small now it's
not the size as it was
the population is small
so
it's better than it was
it's like it settled down
i'm sure bad [ __ ] happens there but it's
just not to the extent as it were
back in the 80s
no
and 70s [ __ ]
that was full on collapse
all right so uh where were we so we were
talking about uh george hennard this
[ __ ] [ __ ]
wants more ice and net yeah that's still
my first drink i think oh yeah i do i i
know but i dropped your uh your eye
patch
uh we're still talking about george r
the looby's massacre
again in case you're just joining us
the
was the worst uh mass shooting in us
history at least until virginia tech in
2007 23 people dead 27 wounded
um so this guy
you know when they did a profile on him
obviously you know loner uh you know
loser kind of guy can't keep a job [ __ ]
like that
um
from the outset he seemed or from on the
surface level i guess um you know he was
an okay looking guy you know he
uh had had a nice house although it was
actually his mom's
but um
again he really really really had
problems with women to the point where
uh several of his neighbors reported
that he would like just randomly shout
obscenities at women as they were
driving down the street like calling him
[ __ ] and stuff yeah he had issues um
he's crazy yeah
um and again might have been gone back
to his relationship with his mother uh
his mom was supposedly
uh domineering kind of high strong and
the two argued all the time
and um
at least one of hennard's roommates in
the military said that he often talked
about killing his mother andrew pictures
of her like cartoon characters of her
as a snake so he had kind of a thing
that women were snakes or vipers uh that
we're always trying to get one over
on four little we've got some poor
little men like himself kind of got
mommy issues uh yeah big time
so yes
uh so uh the media have and uh have
reached out to try to find like what his
mom and dad think about all this but of
course they will not speak to the media
he can't really blame him uh they
haven't been able to find his brother
and sister at least as far as i know uh
they did actually put a pink granite
memorial
uh behind the killing community center
with all of the names of the people that
died the restaurant actually did reopen
five months after the massacre but not
surprisingly most people didn't want to
eat there although it did stay open for
another nine years it closed in
september of 2000. as of 2020 there is
still a restaurant there it is a chinese
buffet called yang sing and as far as i
know that is still there
in the location so if you're in killeen
texas and you go to yank saying that's
where that happened i don't know if it's
the same
actual building or if they tore the
building down and then put another one
there but that's what's there right now
so now let's talk about
the mcdonald's massacre which somebody
brought up before remember this one
maurice hooker says i love you guys we
love you too
cheryl says just saw a dock on samuel
little holy [ __ ] lots of victims and
just kept getting away yeah we did a
show on him a while back he killed that
he was that he was that kind of chubby
balding black dude
he killed a lot of women a lot where
what city
um it was in california i think it was
in l.a something oh yeah or it was
california somewhere he was the one that
was taking the bondage photos of the
looking hookers he was trapped he was
captured right that was there in the
middle of the crack epidemic
that's right yeah and he was able to
[ __ ] hide it inside the crack
epidemic
they didn't attract as much attention
people going well see that's what i mean
and i kind of feel like if serial
killers are still operating nowadays
they're doing that kind of [ __ ] you got
to get involved in a natural disaster
they're like or they're like truckers
and they just kill like sex workers and
stuff like that because or runaways
because no one's looking for them
although that technology that's probably
that's probably also kind of going out
of style because the technology now
they're probably trackers in a lot of
those trucks they probably know right
where you are especially if it's a
company truck well yeah yeah they do
have yeah if you have your own truck if
you're like an independent contractor
maybe you can get away with it but yeah
if you work for a company yeah they
absolutely do have tractors in them
i mean you know i had some [ __ ] coming
from amazon and i went to go check see
when that [ __ ] was coming and it showed
me on the map where the truck was said i
was seven stops away
i sat there and watched it come down the
street and i said i should be seeing it
now i looked at the bathroom window and
there was a damn [ __ ] truck
the amazon truck yeah we have gps now
yeah but it knows where you are in the
amazon app i know i was [ __ ] i was
tripping and i said dude i could see you
on the app it was actually because yeah
it works it's how long have i had that
he's like had it for about a week and i
said i could see i was gonna say i
thought it was new because i usually
because i order a lot of stuff from
amazon you know like shampoo and [ __ ]
like that and um
yeah normally they you'll know when it's
coming to your house like but it'll just
say out for delivery yeah but he came
and ran and showed me the other day he's
like look it's showing me where the
truck is
i'm seven stops so i was like oh that
must be new yeah because it's like i
never saw him do that before like they
tell you what day it's coming dude that
delivered it looked just like interest
elba
really looked just like him did you ask
him no his autograph see you look at his
interest it's like can you pretend
you're interested yeah like sign yeah my
amazon man
is like six foot two look just like
[ __ ] well you know it's the gig
economy man it's like maybe he's gotta
like he's picking up a little bit of
work on the side yeah you know yeah
can't blame a guy
i'm sure he's the same we got that a
week ago
that's cool
i was watching you come down so look at
the window i saw yeah like that's a
little crap i was watching you i was
watching you
see what a time to be alive yeah it was
funny i don't know like some people
might think that's invasive i don't i
think it's neat but you know where the
truck was yeah if i had to you could
drive down there and go get my package
i got to get out well see
i think that's good that they have that
because now that might alleviate like
your [ __ ] getting like taken to the
wrong house right because we have had
that happen we had um when we first
moved in our neighbor
like brought some packages like i had
ordered like some uh like curtain rods
and [ __ ] like that and it had gone to
the neighbor's house
and so she brought him over here so i
think that they probably did that to
like alleviate the situation of like
your [ __ ] your [ __ ] going to the wrong
place or your [ __ ] getting stolen off
your doorstep or whatever
i do like that they send you the i mean
they've done that for a while where they
take a picture of the [ __ ] on your
doorstep yeah there it is and then like
email it to you
so at least you can see that it was
there that's how i knew like one time
that they had sent [ __ ] to my old house
to our old house because i was like
that's not our front porch that's our
old front porch so i had to go back to
the old house and get it
but yeah see i think that's cool
adriana said was hot you would have
liked a delivery man
look at this side hit his elbow with a
beard little beard on him
look like idris elba from from [ __ ]
prometheus
there we go yep
um
all right so let's talk about the
mcdonald's massacre
so this happened in 1984. uh somebody
brought us up earlier in the san isidro
uh neighborhood of san diego
now this was perpetrated by a dude named
james huberty resulted in
22 deaths
and that includes the perpetrator
and uh 19 others were injured
so let's kind of mix it up a little bit
let's we'll talk about james huberty
first and then we'll talk about the
massacre
so this dude was born in ohio weren't we
talking about how like what the [ __ ] is
the problem with ohio and i think
somebody mentioned i think we said
something about it in on one of our last
shows like the easter massacre maybe
and
somebody in the comments said something
about i feel like every serial killer
mass murder is like tai do i have
somehow and i was just kind of like you
might be right about that everybody i
know from ohio was just like couldn't
wait to get the [ __ ] out of there i
don't know what's wrong with that i've
never been ohio is really mediocre maybe
that's what it is
maybe it's just so bland
that it drives everyone crazy imagine if
it's michigan but then it has no
identity
and the michigan's kind of bland yeah
michigan is kind of bland okay
yeah
now i'm now i'm starting to get it yeah
michigan has a lot of character compared
to ohio
yeah i can see that but in michigan does
michigan does have a lot of character
here at ohio yeah it's got detroit
you've had a good sports
[ __ ] you know history and the great
lakes and [ __ ] real beautiful [ __ ]
forests and stuff you know i mean
michigan's beautiful it's cold as [ __ ]
in the winter just cold as [ __ ] but
what is ohio got
ohio didn't really have anything um it's
got [ __ ] dayton and eaton
that's what it's got i can't really
think of it it's like what is ohio known
for
there's got to be something planes
yeah
it's kind of struggling real boring i'm
struggling
[Laughter]
although if you're a young guy in ohio
and you probably look good
and you're in your [ __ ] dress right
you could probably
[ __ ] score some serious tale in ohio
you probably could it's true anywhere
because you'd be the [ __ ] center of
attention do you know
dj manny is it dj manic says cleveland
yeah i've heard cleveland's okay
boring
it's just it's just ohio is just bland
there's nothing wrong with it but
there's also nothing that really like
sticks out about ohio it's just kind of
boring
maybe they like it like that that's how
they like it i've never been there it's
midwest it's midwest as [ __ ] just
midwest so they put ranch dressing on
everything yeah ranch dressing ranch
dressing on pizza they're gonna do that
that's a midwest thing yeah i didn't
actually know about that until recently
i'm like they do what
why
ew i'm not like averse to ranch dressing
on some things it's not my favorite but
i was like on pizza though oh gross
michigan has detroit pizza which i
forgot all about it until i saw it on tv
this is i remember that pizza it's
[ __ ] square
in a little cast iron [ __ ] square
pan yeah it's good yeah
got a lot of cooked [ __ ] crisp cheese
around the edge of it when you get the
slice a little square slice thick like
it's like deep dish
you said thick you said it all sexy yeah
it is
yeah
santa says don't talk bad about the
midwest he said but then he said uh
cleveland is the butt of many jokes to
us midwesterners
yeah
i tell you what i'd rather live out in
the desert [ __ ] new mexico and
[ __ ]
arizona i don't know if i'd want to live
in the desert but i will say i've been
to new mexico and it is gorgeous
me and rob like i just like went out in
the thing and i'm just like
this should not even like be allowed
like what the [ __ ] is gorgeous it's
gorgeous i love it [ __ ] the mojave
not in california my dad just take me
there
looking i know that desert it's looking
it's nice
i'll do some southwest action
great motorcycle [ __ ] flat
flat roads are kind of straight good for
[ __ ] real high speed cruising on
motorcycles
there's not a lot of law and order
there's just order it's the order that
you bring
you can go out there and do a lot of
shooting it's just fun fun area i like
those kind of areas
um you know it's like something out of
the western movies me and rob halford
out there in the desert just leather
daddy in it up [ __ ] rob alfred
[ __ ] saw this he said the same thing
coming from england he saw that desert
and he says that's it i'm gonna live
here
you know i mean it's beautiful it is
desert's a beautiful territory
colorado is nice too i quite liked
colorado also
the mountains are i love like the
snow-capped mountains i'd much rather
live out in a desert than say like ohio
a featureless [ __ ]
i probably would as well yeah although
like i said i'm not a big fan of hot
weather but at least the desert i mean
it's hot but at least it's dry it's dry
at least it's not like swamp ass like
yeah it's not like here it's not an
oppressive heat
you can go out there and go oh man it
feels great it's [ __ ] 100 and
something degrees but it feels good
because your sweat glands work your
cooling system still works yeah the way
that nature intended wait the way it
intends it doesn't work like that here
here it's like being wrapped in a
plastic bag you're just [ __ ] always
and you're not really sweating normally
it's just
terrible
it is terrible
i never quite got used to it i just
tolerated
well like i said i was born here and i
still
and i still never got used to it just
got tolerated
yeah no one likes it you just kind of
have to you have to put up with deal
with it
uh okay so where was i yeah so uh 22
people dead in this uh mcdonald's
massacre included that includes the perp
and 19 others uh injured so james
huberty born in canton ohio
now when he was three years old he got
uh polio and he did recover but uh he
had a limp flake for the rest of his
life
now in the early 1950s his dad had
bought a farm in amish country in
pennsylvania
uh his mom huberty's mom was just kind
of like absolutely not i am not moving
out to amish country to the rural
whatever she's like i don't think so so
she [ __ ] took off
so she like left the family
um
which okay but
she decided she was gonna go be a street
preacher
uh for the southern baptists
so she ran off and did that like left
her family behind and apparently uh
james huberty who was quite young at the
time uh this was kind of a big like
formative thing that happened when he
was a kid his mom just taking off and
saying i'd rather preach on the street
than hang out with you
with the amish and their fudge and their
lack of buttons
1962
james huberty enrolls in a jesuit
community college got a degree in
sociology
uh then later went to a uh the
pittsburgh institute of mortuary science
and got a license for embalming
apparently he wanted to work in
mortuaries because he wasn't a big fan
of people which i'm not going to [ __ ] on
him for that because i mean there's a
million other things to [ __ ] on him for
i want [ __ ] on for that because i you
know i get it he's just wanted to work
around dead people he didn't want to
work around live people because he
wasn't a people person so you know
uh now while he was at mortuary school
he met his wife aetna as in mount hetna
i don't know if she i don't know if she
was
if she'd been like really big a fat i'm
sure but he would have called her about
ed i don't think i don't think she was
though i think she was normal size so he
married her in 1965 they had two
daughters zelia and cassandra
so they moved they went to uh macelon is
it masalan ohio i can't see i've never
been there uh and he worked as an
undertaker for a little while now uh but
then their house burned down
for whatever reason and they lost all
their stuff so then they moved to canton
now when they moved to canton uh james
huberty got work as a welder
now james and aetna both of them
had a history of uh domestic violence
towards one another and probably toward
their kids although i think that was
well no i guess both of them kind of did
it to their kids
uh for example there was a birthday
party for a
neighbor's daughter
and the mom aetna
you know the daughter zelia was going to
the party and said hey why don't you go
beat up that girl like at the party that
you know or whatever like one of her
classmates so she legit like told this
little girl to go beat up this other
little girl at a party
uh aetna also got into a fight
with that kid's mom
and
apparently like pointed a gun at her
so aetna got arrested
um but the cops didn't take the gun away
for whatever reason
uh james no prize either uh he was very
abusive toward his wife and daughters
he had these two german shepherds that
he let just like run around the
neighborhood and they weren't trained or
anything
so they would get into people's [ __ ] i
don't know if they bit people or
whatever
but some neighbor like came up to him
and complained hey your dog was doing
whatever like that he shouldn't have
been doing
and james huberty says okay i'll solve
that problem and shoots his own dog in
the head
who does that this guy motherfucker's
crazy yeah
um psycho yeah
so uh yeah so uh he also beat up his
wife obviously like i said she was no
prize either but he beat her up like he
broke her jaw at some point
one thing i thought this was really
weird this was a weird detail that i
found so one thing that aetna would do
is that when he got in one of his moods
and like she thought he was going to get
violent or whatever
she had a pack of tarot cards and he
like believed that [ __ ]
so she so she would pull out the tarot
cards and like do a reading and like
tell him his future and it would like
calm him down yeah isn't that crazy but
like yeah she knew that that's what
would do it so that's how she like got
him to calm down sorry
that's my
that's
every single time that like rings you're
just kind of like what's that creepy
noise back there that's my horror movie
phone
phone uh ring
uh yeah he also allegedly uh held knives
to his wives and wife and daughter's uh
throats he used to shoot guns off his
balcony just to blow off steam quote
unquote
seems like not a great idea
uh also a big paranoid conspiracy
theorist
uh he stockpile and [ __ ] in case there
was a nuclear war he thought that the
government was watching him or were
after him or were persecuting him so
again we have somebody with some
[Music]
seems like some schizophrenic tendencies
i do you know i i hesitate because he
was never
formally
uh diagnosed with that and most you know
the vast majority of people with
schizophrenia or other mental illnesses
it's far more likely that they'll be the
victims of violence than the
perpetrators of it but dudes like this i
mean that definitely does sound like
some schizophrenia [ __ ] i'm just saying
that that thing where you think that
everyone's persecuting you you think of
like people high up in the government he
thought government agents and the fbi
and everything like that like watching
him and
we're [ __ ] up his [ __ ]
so there was that turn with
schizophrenia yeah that's what that is
yeah
now
so as i said he worked as a welder for a
little while but then he got in a
motorcycle accident and it caused him to
have like he was mostly okay but it gave
him this like weird like twitch in his
arm so he couldn't uh be a welder
anymore
because uh because of that
so uh january of 1984 um
the family left canton ohio and moved to
tijuana
um but they only lived there for three
months because
james did not know how to speak spanish
and would not learn
to speak spanish so [ __ ] them i'm gonna
learn their language
crazy how old yes dude again how old is
he at this time um oh actually i don't
really know he he's in his thirties and
he's an idiot
when i moved to [ __ ] brazil my
priority was to learn portuguese i was
trying to date brazilian girls
as as a teenager and when you speak
[ __ ] the language
it just starts [ __ ] coming your way
man [ __ ] because then and then all of
a
sudden
yeah i don't want to tell them stories
anymore [ __ ] how i [ __ ] learned to
speak portuguese i had a tutor but i was
scared [ __ ] speaking i could
understand it
well everybody is because you don't want
people laughing at you
so my friends were all brazilian guys
that came out of a [ __ ] higher
education you know i mean like they were
all from private brazilian schools
they spoke english
so if i had i'd speak to them in
portuguese at first and they'd speak to
me in portuguese that was after i've
been there for about a year
they knew i could understand them and
you know what i mean
and and i knew they could understand me
and [ __ ] they started getting pissed
i was like look tell him that this and
that and he's like look no no no you
speak portuguese you speak portuguese
drop your nuts stop [ __ ] having me
[ __ ] translate for you
yeah all right so we're teenagers you
know we're all living in the same
[ __ ] apartment complex you know
there's an enclosed community we had
down there all these [ __ ] like you
have five 20-story apartment buildings
in it
well the downstairs area has swimming
pools and a luncheonette and [ __ ]
movie theaters and everything
so
i got loaded with them you know we're
getting drunk and in a mixed crowd in
somebody's apartment i said [ __ ] it i
got pissed because somebody said
something so i just started speaking
portuguese and they and everybody
started rolling over and [ __ ]
laughing they just couldn't believe it
the gringo speaks portuguese korean
speak for he speaks portuguese i see of
course that's being portuguese and i'm
just you know speaking fluent portuguese
well it's because inhibitions were gone
and you didn't care if anybody made fun
of you right now and from that you knew
how to speak it yeah
and from that day forward i just spoke
portuguese and my [ __ ] numbers of
[ __ ] brazilian friends
multiplied and they've been
friends my whole life
and
they're still friends on facebook and
[ __ ] i talk to them all the time and
they're all [ __ ] doctors and
engineers now
and what's funny is that all the girls
live here in florida now that i grew up
with in brazil
they were all evacuated to safety
but the guys are all back in brazil
working
i can um but now a lot of them live in
um tampa
tampa the girls
i was gonna say i had the same thing
happen because i mean when i was in high
school i could speak pretty decent
french right yeah and we had some french
exchange students come over
and i would absolutely not speak french
to those even though i understood
everything they were saying yeah but i'm
like i'm not saying anything
if i'd gotten drunk with that i might
have but i was too afraid too i was too
afraid to i don't speak spanish but i
understand all spanish
and when i usually if i'm if i'm
speaking to a spanish speaker i don't
want to fake spanish i speak to them in
portuguese and they don't understand
what i'm saying half the time
camp guy says the fbi gets letters and
info on crazies like this all the time
there's several hundred at any one time
oh i'm sure
um
which is scary but i mean it's a big
country there's what 400 500 million
people i don't even remember how many
people there are at the moment uh in the
united states and i'm sure there's at
least like a few hundred at any one time
that think that the government is
actively out after them you know what i
mean and maybe only a couple of those
are right i mean the government might
actually be after them because there are
some people that you know that have it
but
uh so yeah so they moved to tijuana like
for whatever reason because you know
that's another thing this dude
uh
legit hated mexicans okay like that
wasn't a secret like everybody pretty
much know that i don't know why he would
move to mexico but it seems um
[Music]
that seems like right up his alley that
he would move to mexico and just expect
everybody to like speak english to
accommodate him that seems like some
[ __ ] he means so we're taking this [ __ ]
that's that's what it seems like that
seems like the type of dude that we're
talking about he's like i'm gonna move
to y'all's country y'all better [ __ ]
get whiter and like learn to speak
english for maya because i'm here now he
seemed like that kind of [ __ ] i
don't know so he wouldn't learn to speak
spanish so they only lived there for
three months
although the chinese do that they'll
move here and they refuse to learn
english well they also well yeah but the
chinese community has like a large you
don't even they don't even have to don't
even talk to white people yes around
chinese people yeah well like i said if
you move to like a chinatown in san
francisco or anywhere actually or new
york or whatever you technically don't
really have to i mean to be honest with
you it's almost not in america it helps
yeah obviously um you know it makes your
life a little bit easier but depending
on where you come from sometimes you
don't really need to
i'm just saying
um
yeah so they then they moved to san
ysidro uh which is a community in san
diego california
he was able to find work as a security
guard
but
two weeks before
the massacre he was fired because of
poor work performance and
quote-unquote general instability
so you know they saw that coming
uh the apartment he lived was actually
three blocks away from the mcdonald's
where he would eventually end up killing
a whole bunch of people
on the day before the massacre
james huberty called a mental health
center
so
as much of a [ __ ] as his guys at
least he knew he had a problem
you know what i mean i'll give him that
tiny little
.001 percent
of
sympathy
he did know he had a problem and he did
try however lamely
to do something about it okay
he calls a mental health center
um
what he says but okay
some sources say that he said it wasn't
an emergency some sources said that he
did say it was an emergency now
apparently the receptionist on the other
end did not perceive it as an emergency
because he didn't sound like he didn't
say that he didn't sound upset he
sounded very calm
um
so i don't really know
so he was expecting
so he calls and he was expecting them to
call like somebody to call him back and
like for him to have somebody to talk to
and so he like sat there and waited for
somebody to call him back now i will say
the receptionist did misspell his name
um as shuberty s-h-o-u-b-e-r-t-y
his name's actually huberty
h-u-b-e-r-t-y but that's a weird-ass
name so you know
what are you gonna do
he should have spelled it
um
so they didn't call back right away i
think that that particular mental health
center at least as far as i could
determine had a thing that it's like if
it wasn't an emergency they'd have
somebody call you back within like 24 or
48 hours right
so apparently the receptionist whether
rightly or not like determined that it
was not an emergency so i guess huberty
was expecting somebody to call him back
within two hours and nobody did so he
sat there by the [ __ ] phone and
nobody called him
now the next morning uh james hubert and
his family uh he had had like some kind
of outstanding like a traffic violation
so he had to go to this the courthouse
in san ysidro so he goes there in the
morning and takes the family with him
because they were gonna like do some
[ __ ] later thank you bryce love the
podcast always probably won't stay till
the end but we'll listen to the
recording well thank you very much we're
very very happy that you dropped by
um
but i was saying before
what i was saying before about him uh he
really didn't like mexicans john goris
makes the point i didn't even think of
this more mexicans to hate in mexico
well there you go i never even thought
that
maybe that's why he's just like i want
to go to mexico so i could hate even
more mexicans at the same time because
they're all right there i don't know
that's like really really funny okay
so uh so yeah so they go to the
courthouse he takes care of whatever his
traffic i guess he had to pay a traffic
ticket or something like that and then
they went to they went and ate in a
mcdonald's not the same one that he
would go and shoot up later on but a
different one so they went in that one
and then they went to the san diego zoo
now according to
the other members of his family
um
they had a very nice day at the zoo just
walking around looking at the animals or
whatever like spent the afternoon there
now
weirdly though while they were at the
zoo
james turns to his wife aetna and says
apropos of nothing
society had its chance
quote unquote that's what he said
society had its chance
he called the mental health hotline they
didn't call him back
in
you know a decent amount of time
yeah okay
so um so apparently he's just gonna
shoot everybody that's i guess
uh
yeah new zealand yeah new zealand
so yeah so uh that's what he tells his
wife apparently they weren't even
talking about anything related to that
uh she just said he turned to her and
said society had its chance so now he's
gonna like do what he's gonna do
so then they get home
that afternoon like about 2 30 i think
it was
and he goes up to his room
or up to the room and gets all his guns
because he was an avid gun collector
they said that he was real um that he
was like real sour like not super
friendly the only time that he was
friendly is if he was talking about his
gun collection that was lighten him up
yeah yeah
uh so he goes and gets his guns
and goes to leave the house his wife
says hey where are you going and he says
i'm going hunting humans oh [ __ ] did she
call the cops no she probably thought
he's full of [ __ ] yeah well the thing
about it like they asked her about this
later and i saw like a little bit of a
snippet with an interview with her i
mean like i said she doesn't sound like
a prize either i'm not gonna lie
but
she said that he said he said weird [ __ ]
like that all the time
so it didn't really register as
something that he was actually gonna do
anything
you know what i mean which
i get it but
i don't know it's like i said it's easy
to say like in the after but if you've
been married to somebody for a long time
and they say like weird creepy [ __ ] like
that like maybe he was always saying
i'm gonna shoot that [ __ ] and
i'm gonna do this and that and the other
thing and it's like oh and he just said
the same kind of thing again like you
wouldn't think oh this time he's
actually gonna [ __ ] do it you know
what i mean i don't know maybe i'm
giving her the benefit of the doubt but
because like i said she didn't really
seem all that great either to be honest
with you but yeah so he said i'm going
hunting humans
and uh she didn't really do anything
about it
uh so now interestingly though
they uh a witness actually did see james
huberty as he went out of his apartment
and walked down
san ysidro boulevard with two firearms
the witness did call the police
but what happened was that the
dispatcher gave them the wrong address
so the cops did come out but they went
to the wrong place initially
so a little before 4 p.m i believe it
was about 3 58
james huberty who was then 41 years old
so this is 1984. he was 41 years old in
1984.
he walks into the mcdonald's restaurant
in san diego uh this you know san diego
right near the california mexico border
if you don't know
about 45 people inside the restaurant at
the time
he was wearing combat trousers a black
t-shirt he had a semi-automatic rifle
slung over one shoulder canvas bag full
of ammunition over the other shoulder
nine millimeter semi-automatic pistol
with a 14-shot clip tucked in his belt
and a 12-gauge shotgun in his hands
so he was uh super armed let's call it
that
so he walks in
uh first person to that he targeted was
a 16 year old who worked at mcdonald's
john arnold he was standing by the
counter uh looked up and found himself
looking down the barrel of the shotgun
another employee says to him hey john
that guy's gonna shoot you
james huberty pulled the trigger but
nothing happened like right in the
dude's face
uh and then at this point james like
kind of drops his gaze like to see what
the [ __ ] is going on
uh and john arnold like just turns like
because he just thought the dude was
kidding
it was like 1984. he thought the dude
was kidding
at this point james fires his shotgun
toward the ceiling
and then he aims uh the uzi
at 22 year old manager neva kane who was
also a newlywed by the way
shot her once beneath the left eye
killing her immediately those things are
worth a lot of money now unfortunately
well
okay they imported a lot of them that
are gone
you can't find them yeah private
collections
oozies
made famous
uh
from the movies
really
they were they were semi-auto this is a
big-ass pistol that's all it was
it looked cool though
but uh yeah what an [ __ ]
yeah oh wait it gets worse yeah danny
rowling says the best fast food case has
to be the one where someone prank called
the fast food restaurant and ordered the
rape of an employee by the manager's
husband yeah we did a show about that it
was well it was sexual assault we did a
show about that yeah it was a strip
search ordered a strip searcher well it
kind of was because i think they did
actually like stick some [ __ ] up in
there so that is technical yeah for some
reason the employee thought that this is
totally legitimate that we did a show
about that yeah we did i think we did a
show about um that and then there was
one other like kind of phone scam yeah
yeah we were doing like a phone scam
show that was like a while back but we
didn't do a show about that it had to be
there was a movie about that called
compliance
something like that yeah that had to be
dude's playing
me and jenny we know exactly what this
is
we we hang out with people from the
fetish community and [ __ ] have gone
to [ __ ] [ __ ] fetish balls and [ __ ]
like that we know fetish when we see it
and if a [ __ ] starts calling me
over the phone all right and having me
start shaking down some teenage girl and
then trying to look up in her snatch and
this and that
i know i'm dealing with a perv
well obviously i think everybody knows i
know i'm dealing with some fetish
[ __ ] that's
trying to play they're like look
fetishes are fine don't involve people
that don't got nothing to do with your
[ __ ] and you're fetish okay yeah you
keep that between you and your
consenting for some reason dude working
at mcdonald's
he either didn't see that or he didn't
want to see that
maybe he really wanted to look up and
girls snatch i mean well there might
have been a little you know i don't want
to impugn that dude's character but
there might have been a little bit of
that and that he had plausible
deniability well i thought it was the
cops you know what i mean but the thing
is is that i know i i can sniff a perv
out i know a perv when i see a perv
i know a liar when i see a liar i grew
up around some of the [ __ ] world's
greatest liars i understand lies and
deceit when i see it and [ __ ] had
weird ass chain of commands in the
military
i know ulterior motives i know it when i
see it
and i guess some people that just didn't
they don't have the proper background
to see [ __ ] but i i see [ __ ]
oh thank you john robertson what do you
say hey guys i'm tuning back in after
work love the podcast my birthday is on
saturday happy birthday happy birthday
but i'll be coming back for the friday
show should be a fun one uh started
listening to the mammoth mountain
poltergeist love it i believe everything
tom said yeah yeah what do you say you
believe everything i said yeah yeah
i want to go back to [ __ ] um chateau
de montage that's the real name of that
place montana
yeah like mountain we called it montage
i know but that's not right yeah
[Laughter]
well it's been so long you know i mean
that's how i remember it basically just
means mountain chateau mountain chateau
but it's montana the thing is is that
i've looked on on google earth and
i know the address and it shows a
building i think that is that address
but i think they may have changed the
numbers
on those yeah i mean it's been a long
time
so
and red's red has died now
he remembered a lot more than i
remembered he was older than me at the
time
and uh lois still wants to go
well i don't really trust her memory she
remembered certain things that i know
that didn't happen
and it's too bad that red died because
red's memory was rock solid
like lois said that she saw certain
things that she saw certain things fall
like the little um
she saw she said she saw the little tab
right go on the window that didn't
happen
i found it like that
okay i found i found it was already
written and the little um twist tie was
below it
on the ground and i was like and it went
like that wow it was that was done with
that the wax on that twist type
that should happen
and the only other case
close to mine
where i think most of that happened
depending on whatever witness in the
book was this house is haunted by
guideline play fair about
those two girls
i have a different take on why the with
the voice thing
okay
that wasn't what it was made out to be
but those movements the cops saw it and
the british newspaper
reporters saw
lego bricks
moving it's the same
rsp man recurrent spontaneous
psychokinesis it happens off and on
to today even in this house
somewhere the last house where it should
happen
but we haven't been here long enough and
i'm getting old getting older so it's
not as like it was when i was young it
was even better
no anyway i'm getting all inside right
maurice says uh what are we drinking uh
i have coconut vodka and pineapple juice
and i think you have a tequila the sun
rises yeah yeah my third one
well [ __ ] i'm still on my first one but
i'm trying i refreshed that oh that's
two
all right i put more in there okay well
it doesn't
i mean the you only filled it up like
that though yeah i didn't i didn't make
it i made it because i am trying to like
get through the cases too so i mean this
is the main one i have like three more
after this but they're short
uh so yeah so he shot the manager who
was 22.
uh then he shot his uh fire shotgun at
john arnold the fir the first kid that
he had held the gun to his face and then
it didn't go off uh he did actually
wound the teenager in the chest and arm
although that kid did live
then he yelled something well he told
everybody to get on the ground some
people he remembered that he started
saying stuff like
uh i killed a thousand people in vietnam
and i'll kill a thousand more
even though uh that wasn't true he
wasn't in the military he had never been
to vietnam so he was just making [ __ ] up
uh he also
said something like dirty swine and
vietnam [ __ ] so you know there was
that
um
at this point 25 year old victor rivera
who was a customer he tried to talk
james huberty out of shooting anyone
else
um
at that point james shot rivera 14 times
uh repeatedly shouting shut up as rivera
screamed in pain he ended up dying
at this point employees and customers
diving underneath tables and booths and
things uh james turns his attention to
six women and children who are all
huddled together like underneath the
table
first killing 19 year old maria
culminara silva with a single gunshot to
the chest
then fatally shooting nine-year-old
claudia perez in the stomach cheek thigh
hip leg chest back armpit and head with
his uzi a nine-year-old girl it was
lighting her up
uh then wounded perez's fifteen-year-old
sister imelda once in the hand with the
same weapon she ended up living
uh fired also on eleven-year-old aurora
pena with his shotgun uh she had been
she was shot in the leg now initially
she had been uh shielded by her aunt who
was pregnant uh 18 year old jackie reyes
uh james ended up shooting reyes 48
times with the uzi
now uh jackie reyes had eight times with
uzi well she tried to shield other
people with her body so he was like
trying to shoot through her it seemed
like uh i don't belong that's kind of
what it looked like to me
um maximum amount maximum maximum
magazine capacity and it was going to be
32 rounds 30 to 32.
unless he were loaded
well yeah he was reloading like the
whole time i don't think so i don't
think these i don't think his uzi was
full auto i think it was semi autumn
and they usually had a the semi-auto
who's he had a shitty trigger pull
hard to fire it fast
i just you know i mean him
you know i just
that's that round count's got to be
wrong
well i don't well i don't know i'm just
i'm going by i'm going by what the
police report says yeah they got to be
wrong uh so yeah so she's dead she had
an eight-month-old baby with her carlos
he sat up and started crying james
huberty shot the kid
in the back of the head yeah so you know
an eight-month-old baby
he then shoots and kills a 62-year-old
trucker named lawrence
vs lewis
then there was a family that was seated
near the play area of the restaurant uh
they had obviously tried to
shield their son and his little friend
beneath the tables uh 31 year old blithe
reagan herrera had shielded her eight 11
year old son mateo beneath one booth and
her husband ronald uh was protecting the
friend who was 12. his name was keith
thomas beneath another booth
ronald herreras told thomas not to move
and you know was trying to shield the
kid with his body thomas got shot in the
shoulder the arm the wrist and the left
elbow
but was not otherwise seriously wounded
ronald herrera was shot six times in the
stomach chest arm hip shoulder and head
but survived his wife blife and his son
mateo however were both killed by
numerous gunshots to the head
uh there were also three other women and
they had attempted to hide underneath
the booth 24 year old guadalupe del rio
uh she was against a wall she uh was
actually shielded by her friends 25 year
old gloria ramirez 31 year old uh oh my
gosh eris delsie of welvis vargas del
rio hit several times not seriously
wounded ramirez unhurt uh vargas got a
single gunshot wound to the back of the
head and died of her wound the next day
she was actually the only person who was
fatally wounded but lived long enough to
get to a hospital
there was another booth james huberty
killed 45 year old banker hugo velasquez
vasquez with a single shot to the chest
now a bunch of calls obviously people
had been calling ambulance police and
everything like that shortly after 4 pm
um
[Music]
what the thing that happened though was
that dispatcher at first again uh led
police at first to the wrong mcdonald's
so they sent them to a mcdonald's that
was two miles away from the restaurant
where it was actually happening uh so
the lockdown that should have happened
didn't happen for several crucial
minutes uh sadly
and honestly the only you know people
that were like driving by or going
buying their bikes or whatever like
other passers by outside were like hey
if somebody's shooting in there like
don't go in or whatever
uh shortly after 4 p.m like you know a
couple minutes after the shooting
started there was a woman named lydia
flores and she drove into the parking
lot and stopped at the food pickup
window and she noticed like broken
windows and then heard uh sounds like
gunfire and then she looked up and
actually saw the dude shooting so she
like reversed her car and ended up
crashing into a fence
she was with her two-year-old daughter
so they just like went and hid in some
bushes so they thankfully survived
405 pm
uh there was a mexican couple uh
astoulfo and
maricela felix
and they drove toward one of the uh
areas of the restaurant now they were
kind of like going in they saw the
broken glass and stuff but they didn't
think
they just thought like oh maybe there's
like some construction work going on or
renovation or something they didn't
really think anything about it uh
because they saw that james huberty like
coming toward the car but he just
thought like they thought he was a
repairman or whatever
so james then fires his shotgun and his
uzi
at both of them and they had their
four-month-old daughter carlito with
them
uh the wife was struck in the face arms
and chest blinding her in one eye uh
permanently rendering one hand unusable
the baby was critically wounded nest
neck chest and abdomen uh the baby was
shot at
um and the husband wounded in the chest
and head thankfully though uh they all
did actually survive
now
uh there were three this
this is [ __ ] terrible too i mean this
whole [ __ ] thing is terrible there
were three like 11 year old boys
and they were riding their bikes into
the parking lot of the mcdonald's they
had actually gone out that day they were
gonna go get donuts but then they
decided that they wanted some ice cream
from mcdonald's instead so they were
riding their bikes to mcdonald's
now they heard they're riding their
bikes and somebody like outside like
yelled at them like hey don't go in
there or whatever but they couldn't hear
it because it was like from across the
street
so all three of them like stopped like
why are they yelling at us and then
james huberty came out because he shot
people outside too it wasn't just inside
and he shot them all with his shotgun
and
uzi joshua coleman uh fell
he had been shot in the back arm and leg
he was critically wounded uh he actually
did live
uh sadly his two friends uh did not make
it so the two friends omar alonzo
hernandez and david flores delgado
uh they were both killed uh several
gunshots to the head
uh there was then an elderly couple 74
year old miguel victoria aloha 69 year
old aida velasquez victoria walking
toward the entrance
uh so they get to the door and the
husband reaches out to open the door for
his wife james fires his shotgun killing
the wife with a gunshot to the face
and then wounding her husband uh and
then basically
man that was [ __ ] up um and then one
of the survivors said that he
said that he saw miguel the husband uh
basically cradling his wife and his arms
wiping blood out of her face and then
like cursing at james huberty like god
damn it you [ __ ] shot her like [ __ ]
like that
he um so james comes up to the doorway
swears at miguel and then killed him
with a shot to the head so that's nice
this dude was just like [ __ ]
wiping people out
uh 10 minutes after the first call was
placed to emergency services police
finally got to the correct mcdonald's
restaurant i mean they got the wrong
info but you know
uh the first officer on the scene was
miguel rosario uh he actually figured
out at first what was going on although
for a long time
they weren't um they did a lockdown of
six blocks around the restaurant they
knew that there was somebody shooting in
there they didn't know how many shooters
there were they didn't know how many
people were dead they didn't know if
they were hostages uh they didn't really
know what was going on so they did a
block off six blocks they later brought
in the swat team they had cops at uh you
know they had 175 officers at a bunch of
locations around the restaurant
and at this point james was still
shooting and alternating between
firearms and they so like i said they
weren't really sure like who because he
had several weapons they weren't really
sure how many people were in there uh
the windows had been all shot up and
were kind of milky so they couldn't
really see in to see what was going on
you know nobody had cell phones it was
1984.
uh so at this point
at first they were kind of like we'll
hold off for a little bit because we
don't know exactly what the hell is
going on in there
but 505 pm
all responding law enforcement personnel
were authorized to kill the perpetrators
should they obtain a clear shot so they
got the green light anybody sees him
take him out like once they determined
that it was just one dude with several
guns
now
at this point uh people that survived
the massacre
they said they saw james huberty walk
toward the cat the front counter and
there was a portable radio there
and uh he started like [ __ ] with it
and they thought at first that he was
going to like listen to news about what
he was doing
but then he found a station with music
on it and he started shooting people and
like dancing to the music
so
great
uh so then he goes into the kitchen of
the mcdonald's and he finds six
employees that have been hiding in there
and he says oh there's more you're
trying to hide from me
uh
to which one of the female employees
have been hiding uh screamed don't kill
me in spanish
uh but you know he opened fire and
killed her she was 21 years old paulina
lopez
on television yeah this was [ __ ] bad
in 1984 84 yeah
also killed 19 year old elsa borboa
fierro 18 year old uh margarita padilla
critically wounded 17 year old albert
leos these were all employees of the
mcdonald's
um
yeah so
[ __ ]
they had all like they had as soon as
the shooting started these had like run
into the kitchen like hid and they'd
been hiding like this whole time
um
leos who actually did survive he was
actually shot five times but he had
actually like had the wherewithal to
like crawl down in there and like hide
so he actually did live
now uh a fire truck then drove up james
huberty opened fire at it uh got pierced
the vehicle with bullets and slightly
wounded one of the occupants of the fire
truck so he was shooting at the cops and
everything too
um so then there was a wounded teenager
19 year old jose perez he was moaning so
james huberty walked up to him and shot
him in the head and killed him
uh then there was another uh girl named
gloria gonzalez who was 22 another young
woman named michelle carncross uh were
also killed
at one point aurora pena
she was uh 11 i believe and she was
laying wounded beside her dead aunt her
baby cousin and two of her friends she
saw a lull in the firing and opened her
eyes and then saw james staring at her
and uh at that point
i guess he looked at her and threw a bag
of french fries at her and then got his
shotgun and shot at her
in the arm neck and jaw she did survive
uh although she was hospitalized longer
than any of the other survivors she was
like very very wounded now as i said
they had blocked off uh six blocks they
had the swat team they had all that kind
of [ __ ]
again they didn't have real good
visibility and the mcdonald's was kind
of like um higher up than the
surrounding area so he had you know
james huberty kind of had like a higher
vantage point so it was kind of like
difficult
um you know so like i said they gave him
uh around like 517 i believe they had a
swat sniper named charles foster and
again they had given the green light
look if you see the [ __ ] like
take him out
um so charles foster had a spotter named
barry bennett they were on uh the roof
of the post office like uh adjacent to
the mcdonald's
and one of the panes of glass busted out
like while james huberty was shooting
and bennett the spotter saw the dude i
mean they knew what he looked like and
everything like that they'd had the
picture
so basically he says to the sniper
there he is
like take him out
so
charles foster
shot one time
and it got right into the d into james
huberty's chest
tore through his entire body shattered
his spinal column
there were four of the other snipers
also shot at him but missed but that one
shot was sufficient it killed him
immediately
so after they made sure that he was dead
uh they all the swat went in there to
see what the problem was to see you know
sort everything out
now
again 22 people dead
22 people dead and that includes the
perpetrator so 21 people we're not
including him
uh september 26 1984 uh mcdonald's tore
down that restaurant
and basically i think they even passed
like the that town like even passed a
law that said
not that you couldn't build anything on
it but it's like we don't want another
restaurant on there because who the [ __ ]
would eat there um they actually ended
up giving the property the city uh they
put they built like an education center
there like part of a community college
and i've seen pictures of they have like
a memorial and it's like all these kind
of like uh granite pillars that are like
hexagons and there are um 21 of them
uh you know representing each of the
victims they're different heights like
depending on their different ages
now listen to this [ __ ] right here
though
two years after the massacre
remember aetna mount etna puberty yeah
the widow of this [ __ ]
she tried to sue mcdonald's
and sue
the company that james huberty had
worked for babcock and wilcox
for 7.8 million dollars she said
that he had snapped and killed all those
people
because
mcdonald's the msg and mcdonald's food
and also because of all the work that
he'd had to do around poisonous medals
like when he was a welder
so she sued right that's a good one
yeah i was like the [ __ ] audacity of
the woman yeah trying to make some money
jesus christ
msg did it
i mean and poisonous medals too but
and msg and she was trying i guess she
was trying to argue that that's why he
was particularly bad at mcdonald's
although like i said i'm pretty sure
that he had cased out some other joints
and thought mcdonald's would probably
just be the best for like maximum victim
carnage okay if you all don't know what
msg is somebody some of you guys might
not be old enough to know what msg is
but my culinary arts ass will tell you
exactly what msg is
back in i think it was 60s 1960s maybe
the 1950s but
i think the 60s
the japanese came up with a new chemical
called msg
monosodium glutamate yeah and it was a
modified version of kind of like salt
it was a flavor enhancer you could put
msg on something it would taste better
there's no way to describe it
msg was a good [ __ ] flavoring
but some people come complain said that
he gave me headaches
i thought that i was having that and i
can't
now the japanese tried to do it a study
to see if msg made you gave you a
headache they said no it's
it can't
um
there may have been a racial component
it may have been that the japanese
didn't get headaches
it's it's um it's not well understood
but i've had msg and as a kid i had msg
and i did kind of get something kind of
like a headache every now and then
from that you could taste it
when you got older you didn't taste it
as much
i kind of but whatever it was msg was
harmless it was not some kind of caustic
thing it was
it was just a flavor enhancer like salt
that's what i mean they still use it in
a lot of stuff but of chinese food yeah
i mean although some chinese restaurants
will go out of their way to say we don't
use msg and stuff because some people do
now i don't know if you might be in the
components that they're using right i
mean i don't know if it's true or not
but for a while um
in the early 90s when i was really broke
and i was eating a lot of ramen noodles
yeah um
those flavor packets have a lot of msg
in them yeah and i was getting my like
bad migraines like every [ __ ] day
right and i didn't really know why that
was until i said something about it to
my mom and she said oh do you eat like a
lot of like you know
asian food or you eat a lot of ramen
noodles and i said yeah you know because
i'm poor
and she's like well that might be what's
causing it um you know msg sometimes in
some people like gives them migraines so
i don't know if that's what it is but
honestly i can eat ramen noodles all day
long it was just like the stuff in the
flavor packets but that was like back in
the early 90s i don't know if it's even
the same mixture anymore and i don't
even know if that's what was causing it
it might have been something else msg
does not seem to give
headaches to asian people it may give
headaches to caucasian and african
people
but there isn't any clinical evidence to
support it just anecdotal evidence yeah
see that's why i don't i'm not saying
that that's what was causing it i'm just
saying that i did
during that time when i was eating a lot
of ramen with the packets i did have a
lot of migraines and i don't really have
them anymore but when you look at the
molecules involved it still should it's
not dangerous it's not poisonous
no no no it'd be all right
i don't even think it's so much people
think it's poisonous i just think people
think maybe some people have allergies
to it which is fair enough you know
because maybe some people do i don't
really know
but that was like uh that was a that was
kind of like the complaint of the day
msg so that's why that [ __ ] was thrown
in there msg did it
it's kind of like ketone remember ketone
kinda
ketone was something you used in making
[ __ ] plastics
and uh they claimed that it was [ __ ]
giving bunch of people cat cancer
and then they they they banned that
ketone
you probably remember that back in the
70s i kind of remember it
dead kennedy's [ __ ]
would write about it in a song stoned by
the ketone factory yeah a factory making
keto
that's funny factories didn't make
ketone
factors used keto but they didn't make
it but
that's what they're talking about
mary connolly says there were 22 people
or many outside the place yeah i mean
it's 22 including uh the perp he got
shot by a sniper um
some were outside there were three
little boys that were outside that were
just coming up on their bikes and they
got shot one of them lived but two of
them died um
and then there was a couple that was
coming in and they were both killed like
while they were inside but he was
shooting at people outside as well um
and more kids got killed inside yeah
some were shot but
you know survived and some were killed
so yeah it was 21 people including well
22 people including the perpetrator
uh so yeah so this [ __ ]
uh tried to sue
saying that um yeah not just msg but
also like him being a welder that they
hadn't really like the company he worked
for hadn't gone through like safety
measures and he was exposed to all this
lead and cadmium and stuff which
might have been true honestly in the mid
80s that doesn't excuse it i'm just
saying that you know it's it probably
wasn't a completely [ __ ] thing what
time of day it was lunchtime there were
45 people inside the restaurant at the
time that he came in that guy says no no
yeah cam guy says you can still buy msg
today yeah in the spice section uh they
call it accent
accent
yeah no way to describe it yeah like i
said it's not illegal or nothing you can
still get it like pretty easily
but yeah so she uh argued all this but
you know she she didn't win she tried to
sue for almost 8 mil and she didn't win
now they did do an autopsy on the
[ __ ] i think they were like
trying to like maybe think about keeping
his brain to see what the [ __ ] was the
matter with them
um
but they i think they just kept it for
like 90 days and then they were like nah
[ __ ] it and they just threw it out
but um
now
when they did an autopsy they did find a
high level of
metal
like
much higher than usual yeah uh because
he had worked as a welder for for a long
time and maybe if the safety protocols
weren't really up to snuff back in the
80s you know maybe he was being exposed
to like some high equipment and maybe
another drink yeah and maybe that did
contribute to like why he [ __ ]
flipped out although to be honest with
you he sounded like not a great person
like from the jump so
i'm not really sure how much that
contributed
uh but yeah so he'd been a welder off
and on for 14 years so it's possible
that he did have some higher than normal
levels of you know cadmium lead
something like that like in his
bloodstream i'm sure that's not good um
but i don't know i don't know if that
really caused all that [ __ ]
uh they found
no drugs or alcohol in his system though
so you know there was that but that's
about the only unusual thing they found
higher levels of uh metal so yeah all
right so now let's talk about i have
like some more cases these are shorter
because those were like the two main
ones because like i said those were
biggest body counts and they were also
motiveless in the sense that it was just
like two dudes that flipped out and just
like walked into like a fast food place
and just like shot
you know a couple dozen people
let's talk about this guy paul dennis
reed he's known as the fast food killer
i think somebody brought him up earlier
so uh he is considered a serial killer
even though he doesn't have the same mo
as serial killers in that it's not like
uh
you know sexual or anything like that
uh but he did kill
seven people
and uh the seven people he killed was
across three
fast food restaurants
in uh in and around the nashville and
clarksville tennessee area and this was
in
1997. between the winter and the spring
of 1997.
now uh at the time that the murders
occurred
he was actually on parole now he had
been convicted in 1983 in texas
he had uh
he had done like a armed robbery
aggravated armed robbery was with the
charge uh of a steakhouse in houston
now he had gotten a 20-year sentence for
that
but he had only served seven years and
then they let him out on parole in 1990
which in hindsight was a big mistake
so this guy was originally from richland
hills texas right outside of fort worth
and he was kind he seemed like um kind
of a [ __ ] bird like one of those dudes
that's just like always in trouble like
nothing
major major
but
you know just like kind of always in and
out of trouble with the law
so he was always kind of in and out of
jail when he was growing up
so
what he did though
at one point i guess when he was maybe i
think he was either a late teenager in
his 20s like he got some kind of like
cash settlement from something i can't
remember what it was it was like
something it was an accident or
something but he got like a big cash
settlement it was like twenty thousand
dollars i think if i remember correctly
and he decided that he was going to turn
his life around which you know fair
enough
and how he was going to do that was he
was going to move to nashville
and become a country singer
so
he used the money
to get plastic surgery to make him look
better or look more like a country
singer or whatever
and then like he moved to nashville like
to try to make his fortune as a country
singer well guess what it didn't work
out
so
he's gonna like go back into a [ __ ]
life a crime
now
these uh three that took place the first
one that he did
happened in a captain d's now do they
have these all over the country or is
this just a southern thing captains i
think south i think it's just a small
thing captain d's sells because we had
one
here good yeah with that we've eaten out
a couple it's nearer to our old house
but we've eaten there several times they
do kind of like southern like soul food
so they do like fried fish hush puppies
yeah okra fried green tomatoes old black
women work at [ __ ] captain d's yeah
back there cooking it's pretty good it's
good
it's like a deep fried
southern seafood
yet
yeah everything's deep fried yeah it's
all deep fried i mean and the shit's
done right
it is really good i mean i i don't even
want to look at how many calories like
one of those platters has but that's a
lot
i mean you know sweet tea
and a [ __ ] any everything that's
[ __ ] southern
big old baked potatoes butter and sour
cream and yeah and if you go in there
on a collard greens
go in there on a sunday you're gonna
find old black dudes in [ __ ] suits
dressed in their sunday best sitting
there [ __ ] eating damn they're in
their 60s and 70s eating [ __ ] captain
d's
and [ __ ]
old black women cooking it it's serving
it and
here you go sugar just everything's just
real southern
very southern yeah
it's a fast food restaurant but it's not
corporate at all
it's like you've gone into a family
business
does it's not like going to mcdonald's
camp guy said i worked at a captain d's
in high school everyone burned their
hands and arms with hot oil when they
dropped the fish yeah what state were
you in
yeah i don't know strawdog 78 said i
used to go to captain d's all the time
in stark florida yeah yeah yeah okay i
love camdees yeah we had one good deal
there we used to go to the one
um
it was probably like a couple of miles
from our old house yeah i don't know if
there's a closer one out here there
might be he says georgia georgia yeah
i'm pretty sure it's just a southern
thing it's a southern thing yeah atlanta
georgia and uh free refills on your
sweet tea you just got there and they'll
pour it out of the picture and it's just
it is a chain restaurant but it has a uh
it kind of has a um
of privately owned business feel to it
it's kind of like you've gone another
one is kind of like that as would be
like wards
wards is a is a
is a chain but it feels like it's
private and i believe that's not a very
big chain
so
good
but um
wards is like not as good as [ __ ]
mcdonald's and because let's be honest
if you've ever been to awards
the wards has a very comforting feeling
to it
just because of the people that work
there and everything's [ __ ] kind of
dilapidated and kind of [ __ ] low
budget the way wards is
i'm going there and get a chili burger
and it's that same thing it's like all
black women working in there
they're the ones cooking and
you get to know them and they know your
name and they give you the [ __ ] and then
you sit down it's like that
and uh it's like everybody in their 60s
captain diesel is like that too
they're all like
50s and 60s and
people okay we got people from louisiana
hold on i lost my [ __ ] chat hold on
let's see
shamarlos is in uh
wait a minute hold on shmallas you live
in louisiana are you from china
okay
think we got trolled in there
okay
no no i'm reading what they're saying
strong dog says he's going to cap these
all the time and start florida yeah i
said that already yeah
going through there
d stands for dano i don't think it
stands for that does it i don't know no
all right let me get back to where it
was okay so first one he did
uh happened at a captain dees this was
in uh donaldson tennessee
morning of february 16th 1997
uh reed comes into the store before it
opened uh he was said he was applying
for a job
once he got in there though um he forced
employee sarah jackson who was 16
and the manager steve hampton who was 25
into the cooler and tied their hands and
feet together
then he made them lie on the floor and
then shot them execution style
so
they found a bunch of money and a whole
bunch of change missing from the cash
register
reid used the cash from this robbery as
a down payment on a car two days later
so that's nice
all right shamar lost you talked too
much [ __ ] putting you in timeout why
you're seeing
you just
it's just random [ __ ]
it's just random just saying random [ __ ]
over and over again just two there we go
get your thoughts together before you
start talking
all over the place nobody talking to you
bro
nobody knows what a shamar loss is
don't get hostile okay
[Music]
yeah no kidding
so this time
the second one he did
the second one he did uh was at a
mcdonald's and this was in hermitage
tennessee evening on march 23rd 1997.
uh this one reed goes up to two
employees uh behind the store after the
story closed uh holds a gun in their
face and forces them back into the
restaurant
uh he shot three employees to death
execution style in the storeroom that'd
be andrea brown who was 17 ronald
santiago who was 27 and robert sewell jr
who was 23.
uh he also tried to shoot another
employee jose gonzalez but his weapon
failed
so then he stabbed gonzalez 17 times and
left him for dead gonzalez actually
lived uh by playing dead uh although
being stabbed 17 times i'm sure was not
fun
reed then took three thousand dollars
from the cash register
and took off
uh so yeah so gonzales did survive and
he was actually instrumental in getting
reid uh put into prison because he
testified against him later on after
they caught him
the third one that he did was at a
baskin-robbins and this was in
clarksville tennessee april 23 1997.
so he goes to the door after the
restaurant closed and persuaded the
employees to let him in
i don't know how he did that
once he was in there uh he kidnapped
angela holmes who was 21 and michelle
mace who was 16
forced both of them to dunbar cave state
park
and
essentially assassinated them their
bodies were found the next day with
their throats cut
june 25th 1997 reed goes to the house of
a shony's manager
who had fired him from a dishwashing job
the day before the captain d's murders
so i guess
he got fired from being a dishwasher and
he just decided he was gonna just go
kill people at random ass [ __ ] fast
food restaurants what the [ __ ] man
i don't understand how these dudes minds
work at all but uh yeah
so he got fired uh incidentally from the
shonies
for throwing a dish
at one of his fellow employees so he had
like anger issues
so
this guy goes to the shoni's manager's
house with a knife
goes up to the front door and tries to
get in
uh but the door was locked now the man's
son was videotaping the whole [ __ ]
[ __ ]
so the footage did uh later get sent to
the cops like after this douchebag got
caught
so
after he you know after the dude
wouldn't let him it was just like no you
can't come in uh he left
and he after that he got arrested by the
national police because obviously they
had called the cops
and because of the way he was acting and
like the [ __ ] he was up to
um
he was like they were like oh this must
be the guy that's doing all these fast
food [ __ ] crimes around the place
uh so he was actually charged in the
captain d's and the mcdonald's murders
at first and then later on uh they
pegged him for the baskin-robbins ones
as well he got convicted seven counts of
first-degree murder there were three
different trials because like i said it
was three different uh cases
and uh basically so the captain d's
murders
they had actually found steve hampton
who was the manager of that captain d's
they found his driver's license and his
video rental card
they found them in the median of
ellington parkway which is nearby and
they had reid's fingerprints on them so
he had actually taken the kid's wallet
well he's not a kid he was 25. but he
took the guy's wallet
and then like threw them into like on a
median and his [ __ ] fingerprints were
on him so not a [ __ ] genius
uh so that kind of like you know put him
uh in proximity to the victim so you
know cheryl says that [ __ ]
washing dishes makes her want to murder
people
once it makes me want to murder i get it
yeah i know i feel that
i mean i kind of feel the same about
uh
laundry and cleaning the bathroom and
frying like that friday do you want to
go to mannequins on friday
after the show we came okay we'll check
this out what electa and [ __ ] tony
want to come over and visit you want to
do that on a friday before we go out
maybe we'll all go out together
maybe even aaliyah aaliyah wants to come
to
come out and go out i figured maybe we
get some pizza we have them on the show
before we go out
we could you want to have a big show
where we got
tony and the ladies where we have a
whole bunch of people they have a whole
bunch well i mean ask them first because
i don't want to ask them right now i
don't want to put people on the show
that don't want to be on the show i'm
asking them right now you know what i'm
saying
because i know they all want to come
over this weekend this week okay
so yeah maybe because because they were
they were all asking aliyah wants must
come over and have pizza
okay
all right well we could do it friday but
like i said they got to be on the show
all right
you know
goth people y'all will love it
it'll be a big attraction [ __ ] um
aaliyah is our adopted daughter
who broke up with our adopted son
it was it was the whole thing it was a
whole thing
and uh elena and tony are long time
friends of ours elite is my
ex-girlfriend that i hooked up with my
friend well you set them up and they've
been together longer than we have
they're married they're married yeah now
yeah
and uh they're [ __ ] they're [ __ ]
funny man they're [ __ ] real funny
you're like they're like a good goth
couple
they're both cute so they're like
everybody would be cute they're all
cuter than us the people we're talking
about
well they're younger than they're young
no so that helps no
elena's your age almost i think maybe at
home i think she's a little bit a little
bit younger that's but maybe only a year
or two
but yeah but tony's quite a bit younger
yeah and eleanor is very much younger
yeah she's only 19 or i think yeah leah
is 19. yeah
uh but yes her homeless ass she that
she's homeless
yeah i heard yeah she was out on lee
road in a motel with some dude
oh i hadn't heard that yeah and i said
oh no daddy doesn't let doesn't let you
[ __ ] go to over there and she's like
no i'm all right you know what i mean
and that dude was doing fentanyl and
[ __ ] that says no you're getting out of
there okay she's not there now
man she said it should have stayed with
him now she's [ __ ] gotta run away
yeah but you know it's like [ __ ]
they're they're they're young and they
gotta [ __ ] learn okay kaylan higgins
says shonies is real
yeah
of course
they're uh i don't think have i ever
been to shonies shoni's is good i think
i've been there maybe one time i
remember their biscuits being good uh
other i worked at the showties oh did
you really yeah it was called elias
brothers i've been to the one in daytona
beach i don't even know if it's still
it's called elias brothers in michigan
oh okay but it's the same thing
yeah or also known as big boy it's the
same thing
oh i didn't know it was the same thing
as big boy we don't have big boy but we
did have shoni's though we had one in
daytona where i grew up
i don't remember if i ever ate there or
not
i kind of feel like maybe i did
it's one of those places kind of like
cracker barrel it's kind of like one of
those places that's known for their like
big
carb heavy breakfast like if you're
gonna go there you're gonna get like
bits biscuits and gravy and grits and a
big thing of hash browns and [ __ ] like
that it's like you know it's kind of
like one of those places either
like your old grandma and grandpa want
to go like for brunch or you go there
when you're like super super hungover
and want to eat like a big huge like on
sunday morning i want to eat like a huge
[ __ ] breakfast it's one of those
places but i think i've only been there
like one time
um but yeah so uh yeah so that's how
they tied him to the captain d's murders
is that they found uh one of the
victim's
ids
and video rental cards that had reid's
fingerprints on them then the baskin
robbins murders which the third one said
he did uh they actually like they looked
in reed's car obviously as they would
and they found a bunch of forensic
evidence that linked him to some of the
victims from the baskin robbins it was
like blood and stuff like that uh also
he had bought gas with a credit card
near the location of where the bodies
were left because like i said he
kidnapped the girls and took them
elsewhere and killed them
uh so and obviously this wasn't a place
where he would normally be because it
was like 40 miles away from where he
lived
uh they also found
uh some of the victims blood on his
shoes so he got found guilty on two
counts of first-degree murder on that
that was the one trial
now the one surviving victim from the
mcdonald's robbery jose gonzalez um he
lived even though he was stabbed 17
times and he was able to identify reed
as his attacker when he was in court and
he was seen as like a real like keystone
piece of evidence to convicting uh reed
so uh reid was found guilty three counts
of first-degree murder on that and one
count of attempted murder that's that
was the mcdonald's one
now uh so he got seven murder
convictions uh he also got a bunch of
lesser charges uh aggravated robbery
aggravated kidnapping because he had
taken two of the girls away in his car
so he ended up getting seven death
sentences uh the first two uh coming on
april 20th 1999
but uh you know just when you get a
death
sentence you know you get so many uh
appeals
so
if
for whatever reason like his execution
has been stayed a bunch of time since
then uh there was
one he was actually supposed to be
executed in 2003
but then just like a few hours before
that
uh he got a stay
because of like some weird legal mumbo
jumbo that was going on
um after a while though he just gave up
his right to an appeal and just said
[ __ ] it
um
weirdly though like his family members
not all of them i'm sure but a lot of
them are kind of like advocating on his
behalf saying he shouldn't be executed
because he's mentally challenged
but
i would argue
that somebody that i mean the crimes
that he committed
were
fairly wealth i mean
fairly well thought out
i don't really think somebody with
really diminished metal capacity could
have pulled off
i mean because he didn't get caught for
a while it took like a few months for
him to get caught he did it three times
right before he got caught yeah so
i don't know i don't really buy that um
but they were like trying to argue that
maybe he's mentally challenged so he
shouldn't be executed
but
i don't know but he's actually still
awaiting uh execution at the moment
um
in tennessee morgan county correctional
complex
uh fun fact his i'm not sure about
nowadays but when
when this article was written his seven
death sentences are the most ever handed
down to a single person
in the state of tennessee
uh his last execution date as of when
this article was written was 2008 uh but
again there was some legal mumbo jumbo
and he's gotten like kind of [ __ ]
so they still haven't executed his ass
yet
um you know he's kind of like oh this is
special too this is another thing that i
found out
um one of the things that they brought
out of the trial trying to show that he
had diminished mental capacity
was that again just like the other two
dudes we were talking about
he had some weird ass uh
paranoid fantasies
um
he thinks he thought or at least he
admitted i don't know if he was just
trying to get away with something
but he did say that his defense team
were all actors
and that he was an actress and that he's
part of a united states government mind
control project which is called
scientific technology okay and that it's
monitoring him all the time they're
watching him so he's another one of
those [ __ ] like i said i don't
know if he actually believes that or if
he's just trying to get
or yeah or if he's just trying to go
look how crazy i am like don't give me
the death penalty i'm not sure i think
i'm not a fan i mean yeah i'm kind of
late into that too
um and honestly the prosecution is not
buying it either they're just kind of
like yeah i think that he's just
pretending to be nuts like that just so
he doesn't get executed but you know
um
so actually as a result of these
murders in 1997 uh some changes were
made at least uh in the nashville area
to fast food restaurants um a lot of
them started closing earlier instead of
being like open late at night uh they
started having like police patrols
uh around them like to check on people
and they had uh they had a thing for a
while in mount juliet tennessee which is
right outside of nashville
they had this thing where like everybody
that worked at a fast food restaurant
you had to have like a decal in the back
uh window of your car
so that when the cops were driving by
they could see immediately like after
closing they could see immediately like
who worked there and like if there were
any weird cars that didn't have the
sticker like they could come and check
it out so there was that
now interestingly for a time this
[ __ ] the fast food killer was
considered uh the prime suspect in the
next case i'm about to talk about which
was the browns chicken massacre in
palatine illinois in 1993 uh because the
crime was very similar to the incidents
in nashville uh but uh he did have an
alibi for that and that did check out
and as it happened as we will discover
shortly the browns chicken massacre was
carried out by somebody else entirely
but you know there was a connection
there for a little while
so the next day okay
so i got a couple more but they're short
so are you we're only at three hours
oh
yeah
i mean that's kind of short and wait for
something
i thought he couldn't like wait long
enough to a general store away from him
he went to he went to dollar tree i
didn't even know you i didn't even know
you went to dollar general he just he
snuck off to dollar general well i was
working and like not even paid attention
to what he was doing
and he comes back
and he had spent how much did you spend
15
wasn't i thought it was more than that
well because you oh you went to publix
too yeah yeah for other [ __ ]
okay so he get he went to dollar general
and all he bought was a [ __ ] ton
of soda and a [ __ ] ton of cookies that's
it i bought the soda at publix
oh okay i got 15 worth of cookies
[Music]
oh i didn't know that they were a dollar
and pound that's right i thought you got
the soda dollar general yeah
no he got the soda publix and then he
got all 15
worth of cookies
so in our refrigerator i looked in there
in the refrigerator to get some ice in
some water and all that's in there is
cans of soda two liters of soda a thing
of filtered water and a whole bunch of
packages of cookies soda
why do you do this
for generic soda was a dollar a two
liter
if you bought five
so five for five dollars
so i went in there and bought five
dollars worth of [ __ ] soda
then i went down to the [ __ ] dollar
general store over here and had big old
packs of [ __ ] lemon cookies different
kind of cookies
or generic oreo cookies
vanilla cookies i mean i like the lemon
ones that you got waivers i like the
liquid i like some waffles i like the
[ __ ] dollar a pack
so i bought a [ __ ] ton
yeah there's a bunch of them they're
beautiful beautiful
now i got gummy bears and chocolate chip
cookies too but we ate all those ate
them we was a dollar 20. last night we
were watching uh we were watching the
terry gilliam movie jabberwock weren't
yeah weren't those cookies good
they're all right for a dollar 25. i
mean for a dollar 25 yeah
um and we ate the whole pack well we
didn't eat the whole package because we
had eaten some prior to that yeah yeah i
think i ate like two or three like a
couple days we had a [ __ ] sleeve each
yeah
they were pretty good
eating chocolate chip cookies and
watching jabberwocky needed some milk
though
yeah we don't have any though we have
almond milk but i don't think we have
any regular milk too i got powdered
built
well that's not really this i could put
some ice in it make this your nice gold
that's good i don't know
um
let's see what's this scumbag's name uh
paul dennis reed is i think his name was
the guy the fast food killer he's on
murder pedia and everything xanada says
soda is so bad for you tom
i'm not worried about it
i'm not a like i said i'm not a big fan
of soda every now and then like he's
sugar-free so he did get some dr pepper
zero yeah yeah um every now and then
i'll be like ah why not i'll have one of
those but normally
like i said all i all i drink is water
coffee
and booze
that's pretty much it just that full
blow full-blown [ __ ] soda is bad for
you it's got all that sugar
but it's actually not the sugar it's the
[ __ ] corn
that's the it's that what he called
corn corn syrup that's bad for you
sugar is a lot better for you but um
the uh the zero should the zero sugar
coal is good
that's nutrasweet
there's nothing wrong with that
and even the diet stuff that has like
aspartame in it that's not that bad
people think that that's just bad have
you noticed that they don't really call
things diet anymore they usually they
usually just call it like whatever zero
or something yeah you know
because diet kind of has a word like
what i i was reading actually i was
writing like a fashion
no i was reading a fascinating article
about it the other day and they said
they stopped uh calling things diet when
they started trying to market diet sodas
toward men
because they because dudes don't want to
be like i'm not on a diet [ __ ] that so
they had so they started putting [ __ ] in
like black cans and calling it like
[ __ ] coke zero and chili because that
sounds more badass than diet coke or
whatever well it tastes better than the
aspartame base that's true because
aspartame doesn't taste like
metal to me yeah it's kind of got a
weird taste to it i mean not overtly but
like the aftertaste like it leaves like
a weird metallic like saccharine is a
little bit better
uh but the best is nutrasweet nutrasweet
tastes a lot better
most of the stuff that says zero
on it is nutrasweet
which is it neutral sweeter do they use
splenda nowadays
might be splendors because i think
they're saying because i i put splenda
in my coffee and that's splendid
nutrition that tastes passable it
doesn't taste like sugar but i think
splendid and nutraced are the same thing
they're just brand names
yeah i don't know
uh but now it tastes a lot better
i mean almost it's almost like sugar
yeah
danny rowling says diet fresca is manly
do they still they still make fresco
yeah yeah it's great they're in flavor i
used to love fresco when i was a kid
when i was little my dad worked at a
magic market harry managed it
and
so i would my mom would drop me off at
the uh store or she would take me by the
store like really early and she's like
you can pick out what you want like to
take to lunch with you yeah and so a lot
of times i would pick out i'd get like a
little sandwich and then i would get a
little thing of uh mint cookies because
i loved those and i'd always get a
fresca yeah all those diets that's when
i was like six
all those diet drinks you can't mix that
with alcohol alcohol [ __ ] up whatever
chemical that is
to make those artificial sweeteners
but the regular stuff with sugar or with
cornstarch corn syrup you can mix
alcohol with that
grapefruit excuse me
fresca
regular fresca and vodka it's great
together it's really good
a lot of people don't know that vodka
and squirt is really good i can see that
vodka works with pretty much anything
that's what i like about it it's very
versatile
it's very well it's cost effective you
buy a plain vodka you can mix it with
any soda or juice or anything like that
and it tastes fine yeah
but fresco and squirt are nothing to be
laughed at when in in in the world of in
the world of alcoholics okay put some
[ __ ] put some vodka in that [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and a little twist
on the rocks oh [ __ ] well i even like
grapefruit vodka yeah in small doses uh
if i have too much then it will make me
barf because it's very acidic
anything that's real acidic i'm just
kind of like i'll have like one or uh i
have one or two and i'm like oh this is
so good and then i'm like awful and then
it'll be like give me a really bad
heartburn and then we're gonna have a
party friday we're gonna have the kids
over friday
afternoon i'll feed them and we'll
[ __ ] get ready here and then we'll
all go to the [ __ ] club and if they
want to crash here overnight we can do
that
yeah we got room we got real like a
crash here well that'll be i don't have
beds for them but i got
you just like threw some blankets
i got a [ __ ] sleeping bag
[Laughter]
yeah we got couches yeah i got capsules
we got a couple couches downstairs yeah
they could sleep until the cats have
like have the cats staring at them all
day
but um
yeah like i said well we can't
we still got to do the show friday night
so we can't do yeah we'll do it but so
we can't be too [ __ ] up no before the
show starts it makes more sense to have
them over connor early
yeah feed them
yeah everybody come over and eat we can
do the show and have a couple drinks on
the show and we'll go over and then
we'll come back and then we can uh
because they live kind of far
you know what i mean that's the thing
about like having the house way out here
is yeah
now it's like really far for everybody
to come out but no i mean we kind of
lived kind of far away elena and tony
live far from mannequins oh
this might be shorter i'll we'll i'll
talk to them we'll see they might go
back well wait have they moved since
last time because we haven't been over
to their place for a long time laughing
at a new place
yeah that's been a it's been years elia
doesn't live anywhere if she wants to
[ __ ] crash yeah she used to live
right downtown yeah she's like a couple
blocks from barbara i put her up in the
damn sleeping bag i [ __ ] got the
sleeping bag i got to sleep in matt too
yeah under my
was up there drinking out of this thing
yeah uh xanada says fresca is good we
used to do gin and squirt did it work
yeah i can see that i could see that
vodka would be better though i mean i
like yeah i like gin but again i have
the same problem as i have grapefruit
vodka it's just it's good but it's like
two aside vodka is larger
more conducive to mixing with any kind
of soda because it doesn't it doesn't
have
it doesn't alter the flavor of soda that
much now some people like [ __ ] jack
and coke and whiskey and coke
which yeah that might work but whiskey
wouldn't work out with anything else
some people just like jack and coke but
i mean i've had like [ __ ] coca-cola
and whiskey's even coca-cola and vodka
is probably even better
i don't think i've ever had that i've
never had it i like jack and cokes
i don't think i've had whiskey i've had
whiskey soda i don't love it but
whiskey and coke is good
but i've never i don't think i've ever
had whiskey i bet you mixed with
anything else i bet your vodka and
[ __ ] ginger ale is good
oh yeah i don't see how that could be
bad well like i said that's vodka
doesn't really taste like anything like
anything right other than like booze it
doesn't conflict with anything right
that's what i like about it like i said
you get a big bottle of it for 20 bucks
and like you can mix it with anything
you got you got whatever soda you got
whatever juice you got whatever anything
you got it'll taste fine
i mean some things some mixtures are
better than others obviously but
anything's you know you can mix it with
anything that's still drinkable
all right so
oh
santa says if you mix squirt with gin
you can't tell good gin from badging
well that's always a plus but if you if
you're like us you got enough money for
good gin so why are you white although i
never buy it i do like it i have it when
i'm out sometimes but you like maybe
once every
six months or something i'm like oh i'm
in a gin and tonic
gin is only good with tonic gin and todd
was and it's gotta have lime in it lime
and that's it i i couldn't imagine chin
in anything else like
you have it and [ __ ] they put gin in
those [ __ ] martinis what's in a gin
ricky i don't know it doesn't taste good
to me i it's just
that's with tonic water
a little bit of lime
yeah i like them but it's i don't buy it
because i'm like well i like bombay and
that's like uh you know
uh
that's kind of like a big thing i don't
know how much is that thirty five
dollars yeah bombay is a pretty good one
pretty good gin bomb-based sapphire yeah
yeah that's i think it's thirty five
dollars in it something like that for
like a real for a big one for a fifth
year and i just kind of feel like
i don't drink it often enough to justify
charge to justify like paying that much
for it for 35 i'd rather have [ __ ]
tequila i mean if i bought it i would
still have it like a year from now
probably
because
every now and then i feel like one but
most of the time i don't cheap standards
beef eater
it's good good and [ __ ] inexpensive
you can mix it with anything yeah yeah
for gin
i like bombay though and that's more
well that's it more deluxe yeah
but it's i mean i'm sure there's other
kinds that are good there are some that
are like super premium but that's the
one that i'm just
got used to drinking and i like that one
all right so uh let me i got uh i'll mix
coffee and cozy ginger beer is amazing
i'd imagine it is
yeah yeah ginger beer
makes me sneeze
yeah i like ginger beer i used to when i
was in the uk my ex-husband used to love
that [ __ ] fiery ginger beer and
actually you can get it in the u.s some
places like we used to get it there was
like a little british market in daytona
and they had it
some publixes
that have a british food section like
our uh one here does i don't think they
have fiery ginger ginger beer though but
um the publix in daytona had it
so every now and then he'd go and get
some cans and i tried to drink like i
love ginger ale but ginger beer
it's good but it's like every time i
drink it i'm always like i immediately
start sneezing that's funny i don't know
what the [ __ ] it just goes right up my
nose like pepper i don't know i want
some more pizza
well you can make one in a minute when
i'm done okay
i got two more short little cases okay
let's go see more short little cases
all right so i was going to talk about
the browns chicken massacre
now brown's chicken i don't think we
have them uh in florida it actually the
first restaurant was in bridgeview
illinois and then it grew to a chain of
300 outlets across 13 states most of
them are in chicago i think as of 2020
20 20 21 uh 2021 there are some that are
still around
but because of this
um that happened
in 1993
a lot of them closed because their
business uh dropped after this happened
january 8 1993
two guys walk into a browns chicken in
palatine chicago illinois just before it
closed at nine o'clock in the evening
they ordered a chicken meal
and then sat down
in the booth next to a trash can
uh so they ate and then they put uh you
know what was left of their food in the
trash
then they put on a pair of latex gloves
and went to rob the place
uh so there was one guy that worked
there named rico solis he was sweeping
the floor and one of the robbers came up
to him and told him to walk to the back
of the restaurant
the other one uh fired a shot into the
air presumably and told everyone to get
on the floor
uh another employee tried to run for it
he jumped over the counter but was shot
before making it and he was then taken
to one of the coolers
and then uh one of the franchise owners
richard ellenfeldt uh was also taken to
the cooler
and then a couple seconds later people
outside of in the restaurant like heard
a bunch of shots coming from inside the
cooler
so after they had killed these two
employees one of the robbers
had uh the franchise co-owner lynn
ellenfeld who was the wife i guess of
richard ellenfeld
and uh told her to get the money out of
the safe
then after she had done so he slit her
throat and then took her body into the
walk-in refrigerator and then the rest
of the four employees were in there now
this is like [ __ ] up but like late so
later on they found out that the four
employees that were in the walk-in
uh they were like basically begging for
their lives as they would be
um but the robbers just opened fire
into the walk-in refrigerator and uh
pretty much uh killed them all
now
the massacre that night
the robbers got
less than two thousand dollars i think
it was about 1800
bucks 1800 1900 somewhere around there
so that's nice they killed seven [ __ ]
people for that paltry amount of money
so the people that were killed were
guadalupe maldonado michael castro rico
solis
thomas menez marcus nelson
uh and then the franchise owners richard
and lynn ellenfeld uh there were no
survivors
of this massacre now
how they found out okay
so this right here is kind of [ __ ] up
so the cops get called
i think the first people that called the
cops were the parents of one of the
employees because they were like well
you know uh our kid hasn't come home and
it's not like him to not come home like
not be this late and not call us and say
where he's at
um
so like but the cops initially they kept
like driving by the restaurant but they
didn't see anything from the outside
they just saw like cars in the parking
lot
they saw the lights were damned as
though the place were closed they didn't
see anything that looked weird from the
outside and they seemed like
not really to give a [ __ ] or they really
didn't want to investigate they're like
oh
those kids they probably just all went
and had a drink together damn teenagers
it was that kind of i kind of got that
impression like from the um [ __ ] that i
was watching about the
police response to this they really
seemed very lackadaisical
at first they just figured oh all the
employees just left the restaurant and
went to get a drink somewhere without
telling any of their family where they
were going or what you know so the cops
didn't really want to do anything about
it
uh so basically it took a while though
and and honestly finally by the time
they got i think there was one cop that
was kind of like hey this is like looks
weird but a lot of the other cops were
like nah it's fine
now so the cops get there they find the
back entrance unlocked like i said it
don't look weird from the outside but
they did find one of the back doors
unlocked
so
eventually finally
there was one cop that was kind of like
you know this looks [ __ ] up the safe
was open there was like you know some
money that was kind of like laying
around or whatever and at first the
other cops were kind of like oh well
maybe all the employees just took the
money
from the um
safe and like went off someplace because
they were bad at the management like
they didn't want to investigate or
whatever and it was just that
and it's kind of like i don't know it
was just like this big thing
uh so
what happened uh so
they find the back door unlocked and
then they all come in and then finally
they go into the walk-in and they see
all of the seven people dead
now
interestingly uh they're investigating
the scene there's this one woman who was
a dr homeyer
she was a forensic investigator
now she saw this is 1993 so dna was
a thing but not really that big of thing
you know what i'm saying
she looked in the trash can
and she saw that there was like part of
a chicken meal left in there like that
somebody had partially eaten
and she had the presence of mind
to save that because she saw i mean they
look at the um you know the tickets the
receipts from the cash register and
she's like this
meal was bought at 908 which was eight
minutes after the restaurant was
supposed to be closed
so she's like well maybe this has
something to do with it so she kept it
now they couldn't do dna on it in 1993
but she
thought to herself well i'm gonna keep
this just in case and she put it in an
evidence freezer right so she just like
kept it
now uh they also found because like i
said they're you know they'd kind of let
the um i believe they let the employees
in the next day because they didn't
think anything was the matter they let
like people come into the clean or
whatever
uh so
basically
what happened was that this case
was like dormant they didn't know who
did the [ __ ]
for nine years
like i said they still had this meal
that she was keeping in the freezer
but that's about all they had no one
really saw it happen and everybody was
dead
now in 2002 though
this girl comes forward this woman named
anne lockett
she comes forward and she says
uh my boyfriend at the time james
dagorski
uh
was probably one of the guys that did
this
she she told police she said a couple
hours after the killings took place
he had told her quote watch the news
tonight i did something
and later on she says he told her
exactly what he had done
and he said look it was me and it was my
friend uh juan luna we're the ones that
did this and you better lie for us or
i'm gonna kill you oops
it went red
what
it's back okay it's back
it went red there for a second but we're
back i didn't say anything while it was
red because i thought you took it
i'm just like 56 degrees outside you
believe that it's ridiculous it's
january that's [ __ ] cold for florida
but it's january i mean this is about
that's not that it's february that's
standard or february right yeah it's
it's standard for this time of year
i mean you know it's not that cold but
it's for for florida it is
um
so yeah so so the girlfriend the
ex-girlfriend rather comes forward and
says look you know they told me they
would kill me if i told anybody but you
know we broke up now and hopefully
everything will be all right so she came
forward and said what happened
so
uh the cops
arrested both of them
and
got them to give dna swabs
now the results came back and juan
luna's dna was a perfect match
for the saliva that had been found on
the chicken dinner that that one
enterprising
doctor that forensic investigator had
all those years ago
dug out of the garbage and kept in a
freezer for nine years
they were able to match one of the
people's like i said nine years later
so it did match
uh they found out too that luna used to
work at the restaurant but was fired
so because he had used to work there
he knew that the restaurant didn't have
any alarms he knew where the money was
like he knew where the safe was
and uh he knew that the owners didn't
keep uh any weapons
on you know so he knew it would be like
i said a soft target
so may of 2002 uh luna actually
confessed to the crimes uh he said that
him and his friend james dagorski they
had been friends in high school
uh came in the restaurant just it was
closing at 9 00 pm ordered uh chicken
dinners and then forced the staff to the
back of the establishment and executed
them
and they later got jailed for life
now this uh browns chicken chain
uh the president of
brown's chicken then was a guy named
frank portillo
and he said after this happened
um
the sales at all of the restaurants and
like i said we don't have brown's
chicken here but i think it was kind of
like you know it was around chicago and
around that area uh he said sales the
restaurants dropped by 35
in the months following this incident
um
so basically they had to close about 100
of their restaurants in the chicago area
and uh i think it's still around
nowadays at least last i heard i don't
know if the pandemic like you know put
the stake in it or whatever but i heard
that there were a few locations still uh
around chicago and some other places but
i don't know if they're still there or
not but they did how to close a bunch
um now the building that uh that this
took place in is no longer standing uh
it was revamped as a dry cleaner and
then a deli and then they demolished it
in april of 2001
and uh then it was empty and then they
put a chase bank branch office on it
now last one i want to talk about this
one is actually i don't know if i want
to get into this one though because this
one seems like it needs its own show
okay well then if you think that then
don't do it i mean it's been going on
proof i mean it's short but i kind of
want it this one's different it's the
burger chef murders this one's different
but it's like unsolved
and the more i read about this one the
more there's like all these kind of like
twists and turns and stuff and i kind of
feel like i want to get into that
and i kind of maybe think it needs its
own channel we're gonna do the birdman i
mean i kind of feel like maybe at some
point we should do another
show of this because i wanted to do the
austin yogurt shop murders too
and maybe we could do those two on the
same show
because i feel like at this point we've
been going like three and a half hours
and we can we can go ahead and wrap it
up and i just don't want to like and
we'll do that i don't want to give it
like short shrift and i gotta [ __ ] um
make it something aren't you hungry yeah
i'm lobbying okay
go ahead and shut it down though people
it was nice seeing y'all
and uh
jenny's gonna close us out
i'm gonna go ahead and start a somebody
yeah xanada says burger chef is a deep
dive that's what i was thinking like i
was thinking about it but then the more
i was thinking about talking about i'm
like man there's like so much stuff
around that one and like i said because
that one's unsolved i kind of feel like
that needs its own show
so maybe we'll do another show with just
burger chef and austin yogurt shop
because i think that one's unsolved as
well so
we'll kind of go uh yeah zach said i
listened to an episode of unresolved
about this it's super interesting and
creepy yeah so i do kind of feel like it
needs its own show so that's what we'll
do
uh cause i'm getting kind of sleepy and
kind of hungry so you know yeah mango
says i'd love a longer show burger chef
yeah we'll definitely do that um you
know as usual i bit off the one i could
shoot but i wasn't sure i'm never sure
like how many cases because sometimes it
goes really fast sometimes it goes
really slow and i had a hard time
picking but you know but yeah i'll save
that one for another day
uh but yeah so thanks everybody for
dropping by this wednesday evening
and uh thanks for all your super chats
we will be back on friday night might
have some special guests we'll see how
that all turns out uh hopefully it all
turns out it might be a disaster i don't
really know it'll be fun anyways but
yeah so uh be sure to drop by on friday
for our sidetrack show which if you're
new here is
just uh free for all questions no topic
we just kind of talk about whatever so
we'll see you guys again on friday again
thanks for dropping by have a good rest
of your evening and we'll see you later
bye